foreign
firstly I'd like to welcome you all to
this virtual meeting of mid-suffic
District Council it's the first one
we've had in 2021 so happy New Year
let's just pray that this next year or
this next 12 months is safer and better
in every way than the previous 12 months
before we start the meeting my first of
all reminds you of some domestic
arrangements please ensure that
microphones are muted when you're not
speaking that you do not interrupt other
speakers members are reminded not to use
the messaging or chat function during
the meeting unless it's to report
pecunery or non-cunary interest or to
notify the chair that you wish to make a
proposal
that's if you're attending the meeting
to speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
Additionally you will be invited you'll
be invited to speak and ask questions by
the chair please await your turn if
members lose connection on the meeting
that they that they then contact the
member supports officer Mandy Smith as
soon as possible so we can get you back
in is really important and as this is a
virtual meeting you will not need to
stand to address the chair
I would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable
capable of repeated viewing the whole of
the meeting will be filmed except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being filmed by
entering this meeting you are also
consenting to being filmed by the
council and to the possible use of those
images and sound recordings for
webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public
account the council members of the
public and the Press May record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and press are not
lawfully excluded and I'd just like to
add please continue in the vein you did
last year of being polite and respectful
respectful for others I remember the
Constitution and let's keep the
etiquette nice and fine and have a
smooth meeting I'll now move to the
agenda
foreign
policies for absence please
thank you chair I have received
apologies for absence from councilor
Guthrie
thank you
um I'd also like at this moment to
welcome back councilor Rachel eberne
um I think I speak on behalf of all
councilors in saying that you were
greatly missed and it's really really
nice to have you back in here and I
believe that you wish to say something
canceriban
uh thank you very much chair
um
I'm very pleased to be back and um I'll
wait in slightly
um changed form from from the last time
you all saw me
um however I would just like to take
this opportunity to thank all of my
colleagues for the kind of thoughts the
flowers cards and best wishes I received
when I was in hospital in November and
December last year and um I'm on the
road to somewhat recovery although my
cancer isn't of the curable kind
um I will always have it um as my
consultant kindly put it I'll be on
chemo for the rest of my life but um but
I'm glad to be back here and it's it is
a real pleasure to to be here tonight to
see all of you and I apologize if I
leave the meeting before the end but I'm
still very tired and if I
um you know I'd rather not fall asleep
on camera and give the meeting as my
full attention as I can thank you very
much and thanks to all of you thank you
counselor Ben and we are really glad to
see you
um are there any
um Declarations of Interest by
councilors
okay there are none
we're now going to move on to mc2015 to
confirm the minutes of the extraordinary
meeting held on the 11th of November
2020 and this is for accuracy only and
those pages are 9 to 16.
are there any issues with accuracy
could have a proposal please
okay uh councilor richson is the
proposer and a second to please
councilor flattman
and asked the corporate manager
governance and Civic office to conduct
the electronic vote
thank you chair cancers can you please
open the vote in the modern.gov app by
clicking the plus sign in the right hand
side of the agenda screen and selecting
attendance and voting in the voting tab
the vote for this agenda item will turn
blue and please click on the blue line
to to open the vote thank you
thank you
foreign
scarf are you able to submit your vote
electronically
I'm sorry my line hasn't gone blue so my
vote is in favor okay I may have this
problem at other votes okay that's fine
councilor Humphries
um we also need your vote and
and counselor
Phillips please
that's affirmative thank you
so I'll say so chair that's 33 4 and 1
abstention
thank you the minister meeting have been
confirmed and will be signed at the next
practical Opportunity by myself and when
I moved to mc2016 to confirm the minutes
of the meeting held on the 26th of
November 2020 again for accuracy only
and they're on pages 17 to 26.
are there any issues with accuracy I see
two hands up I'll take councilor flapman
first please
no problem at all councilor Morley
okay and uh councilor Mansell I'll see
you hand up uh chair I
I've because I think I heard
the officer say that it was 33 4 and 1
abstention but I don't think there are
34 people here thank you really good
spot I will now check that
okay
okay we just had to confirm 32 for one
abstention have a really good thank you
thank you
okay in that case uh can I have a
proposed please
okay counselor um hardingham and a
seconder please
councilor Carter
thank you announce the corporate manage
manager governance and Civic office to
conduct the electronic votes
thank you chair
line in the top right hand of the screen
click on select attendance and voting
and then when that agenda item is blue
click on the blue line to to start the
vote thank you
foreign
Humphreys vote please
councilor Phillips please affirmative
thank you
for one extension yeah
32 4 and 1 abstention chair thank you
thank you and again I'll sign those
minutes of the meeting once they've been
confirmed at the next uh actually as
they have been confirmed at the next
available and practical opportunity
okay uh moving to Mike MC uh 2017 which
is the Chairman's announcements and
refer you to paper MC 2017 for noting
thank you
I just like to say that um obviously
it's very limited in what we can do at
the moment in the current climate hence
the fact there's only two
um places that I actually visited and
one was virtually but I would like to
say a big well done to this still Market
uh dementia Action Group for all that
they did over the Christmas period and
bringing joy to people's homes that
couldn't get out so um it's it's
definitely worth setting that uh that
Carol service thing off it's really good
okay latest announcements
councilor Morley
um I'd like to invite you now to present
your paper and you're upset
thank you chair
this second covid wave is clearly now
much worse than the first last spring
I'm sure you are like me horrified to
see the current level of daily deaths
and Hospital admissions
we are of course in a third National
lockdown but it's going to take a long
time before we will see a significant
reduction in rates of infection
hospitalizations and deaths
Suffolk has been badly hit like all
regions and so we must continue with the
public awareness and messaging campaign
midsouthat needs everyone to stay at
home and follow the lockdown rules
I know you are all doing what you can to
promote these messages across all of our
communities but please can I urge you to
all keep doing soon
as I said District Council we are of
course continuing to support our
residence communities and businesses in
response to covid
I will not repeat the information that
all councilors receive on a fortnightly
basis but I did want to highlight a
couple of particular elements
firstly the closed business lockdown
payment grants I'm really pleased that
these are now available and we have
started to pay qualifying businesses
this week
as we already hold the data regarding
many businesses automatic payments are
being made and these will reach
approximately 70 of the business with a
rateable value who are eligible
in addition new Grant applications have
been launched for any businesses who
have not previously received a lockdown
Grant from us
our website has been updated accordingly
and it is the best place to refer any
business in your ward that may have
contacted you
there are now a variety of government
grants available and the picture has
become quite complex
but again full details are on our
website
including a comprehensive infographic
describing the more and we are of course
guiding our businesses through this to
make sure we make it as simple as
possible and they swiftly receive all of
the money that they are entitled to
the other aspect that I wanted to
mention in relation to covid is the
vaccination program
many of our most vulnerable residents
have already received their first
vaccination
but I know many of us have also had
contact from concerned residents as to
when they will receive their Jab
how they will be informed where they
will need to go and how they will get
there
these are exactly the conversations that
I've been having alongside Council Lakes
councilor Passmore and our fellow
Council Council leaders at our local
outbreak engagement board meetings to
ensure that the communication to all of
our residents is effective clear And
Timely
there are now 19 Primary Care Network
vaccination sites in place across
Suffolk and for mid-suffolk these are
located at debenham Leisure Center
the mixing Stow market and the woolpit
health center
in addition all three hospitals the
James Paget West Suffolk and dipswich
are all vaccinating and a lot and an
additional large site will be provided
in Ipswich shortly
to further Pharmacy sites Ipswich and
lowestoft have also been approved
there is also an increasing supply of
the Oxford vaccine available
this vaccine doesn't have some of the
same logistical challenges as a Pfizer
vaccine which should enable more people
to be vaccinated more quickly
at the moment however there is what is
being referred to as a push model in
place
and that means our local NHS is not
responsible for managing the supply of
the vaccine
but they hope to be able to move to a
pool model shortly so they can draw down
the level of vaccine that they need
based upon demand
in any event they remain on track to
achieve the first two government
Milestones of vaccinating All Care home
residents and staff by the 24th of
January and all of our first four
cohorts by mid-February
we're pleased that an excellent new
suffolk-wide website
www.snevaccine.org.uk has now been
launched but Matthew Tim and I will
continue to push and support the NHS
with regard to effective Communications
to all our residents
we are not directly involved in the
delivery of the vaccination problem at
program but we are supporting and
facilitating it in a number of ways
just two examples of this is the work
our planning assets and legal officers
are doing in support of the wool pit GP
surgery
with the neighboring housing developer
to enable it to deliver an expanded car
park that will enable the acceleration
of the vaccine program in that area
and of course provision within our
existing car park sites such as in Stone
Market to support delivery of the
vaccination program at the mix
we're also a partner on the suffolk-wide
resources cell and so we'll continue to
deploy our offices where possible when
needed to ensure the delivery of not
just the vaccination program but also
the new testing program for
asymptomastic workers who are unable to
work from home
this testing program is expected to be
rolled out over the next few weeks
last night it was the first of what will
be a regular meeting for our district
and County councilors to hear from and
post questions to the NHS
I hope many of you took this opportunity
up those who attended will know that I
asked a number of questions on our
behalf
tonight is also the second equivalent
Community session for members of the
public
I could not miss this opportunity to
highlight again how proud I am of how we
are still continuing to deliver on our
wider priorities during these difficult
times
with this in mind I wanted to mention
the fantastic news published this week
regarding our successful purchase of 121
new Council homes including developments
in Hawley Stone Market and woolpit
this is of a course in addition to the
work already underway to build 130
Council Homes at our former former need
and Market Middle School site and our
former headquarters
I'm also pleased to announce in line
with our customer strategy to support
customers to contact us at a time that
suits them 24 7. we are launching a
pilot tomorrow that enables customers to
easily access online information to new
and Innovative automated telephony and
chatbot services
through this enhancement customers will
be able to log queries such as missed
waste collections find out information
about environmental services and receive
links to our online forms Via SMS text
at any time of the day or night
this pilot will run for 12 months and
provide value insight
valuable insight into how customers wish
to engage with us which will further
inform our plans for Digital Services in
the future
finally I also wanted to highlight the
cabinet's recent decision to move
athletic vehicles in particular our
waste and housing vehicles to hydro
treated vegetable oils rather than
diesel
in line with our commitment to tackling
climate change this alone will cut
approximately a quarter of the council's
total CO2 emissions and 90 of our
vehicle emissions
if any councilors have any questions
about any of these then please do
contact me or the relevant candidate
member outside of tonight's meeting
thank you Jim
customer counselor um
eburn I see you've got your hand up is
this a
um a point of clarification that's
required
question and a point of clarification
thank you chair yeah I'll allow it
normally it's only points of
clarification but I'll lie on this
occasion
um
I hope you thank you very much chair
just to say that the website for the
Snee vaccine it doesn't have a www dot
in front in front of it it's just Snee
vaccine if you put
www.snevaccine.org.uk you get up with
you'll get a message saying so it cannot
be reached so just to make sure we don't
we do publish the um
the correct
um a website address thank you okay
thank you very much councilor even and
I'd also like to to say that there are
links from the Suffolk County Council
website
um across to all of our ccg sites and
other partners thank you
oh very good and and thank you for the
for the comment uh councilor Eben yeah a
very detailed and informative
presentation thank you we're not going
to move on and receive information of
petitions in accordance with the council
procedure rules
thank you chair please be advised that
we have received the following validated
petition
petition relating to the Suffolk County
Council highways response and respective
planning application DC 2004 572 with
183 valid signatures the petition will
be dealt with through the normal usual
planning processes thank you
thank you moving on to questions about
the public in accordance with Council
procedure rules and I refer you all to
the question in the table papers I'd
like to invite Mrs Sharon McGarry to ask
her question and Mrs McGarry please
for meeting government climate change
targets in the 2020 report by government
advisory body the climate change
committee was low-cost low regret
actions to encourage a 20 shift away
from all meat by 2030 rising to 35
percent by 2050 and 20 shift from dairy
products by 2030.
good quality plant-based meals are
healthier and can be cheaper there can
also be more inclusive as the same meal
can be shared by a wide variety of
people including Jewish Muslim and Hindu
people and those with dairy allergies
there's good evidence that a shift in
diets away from meat and dairy products
to more plant-based options is good for
both climate change mitigation and for
human health
will the district council commit to
implementing menu changes that remove
bias towards meat and dairy within its
own sphere
Mr mcgow thank you and I'd now like to
invite councilor Fleming to respond
please yes
um yes good
very much for your question
and your question is really requesting a
commitment from the council to promote a
plant-based diet in an incremental
manner over time whereas I have a lot of
sympathy with what you're saying and we
have communicated independently between
us
this is not something that we as a
council can support for several reasons
including the fact that the council is
not actually actively involved in
catering or supplying food at the moment
but pandemic aside we share catering
services with other organizations at
Endeavor house and we are pleased to
report for the most part our sourcing is
local and the food is varied and
excellent with options for all tests
however I do believe there is widespread
support for better farming and food
production practices and local sourcing
to reduce food miles and emissions
we take the position that these kinds of
choices are for individuals and the
council caters for individual
preferences very effectively it is
continually seeking opportunities to
improve the environmental footprint of
all our services
thank you Mrs McGarry do you have a
supplementary question
we advise food outlets in the district
doing visits and Via bulletins about the
climate and Food hygiene advantages of
vegetarian and plant-based menus thank
you
under councilor Fleming if you'd respond
please
um
thank you again
um I do not see that as being really
our role and we but we do have regular
bulletins for food Outlets but we're and
we're building a database of emails so
in theory this could be done in the
future in terms of of advice to them in
terms of effective sourcing and
reduction in food miles and carbon
emissions our food safety team who speak
with businesses on a regular basis do
talk to outlets about potential changes
to their menus
and if those still operating most are
trying to contend with managing new
takeaway services and it does not feel
right at this time to talk to them about
changing their operations
we continue to support our businesses in
every way possible and should businesses
want to talk about
how they can change their offer with us
we will be more than happy to help them
thank you and Mrs McGary thank you for
your question and thank you for
attending the meeting tonight
we're now going to move on to questions
by counselors in accordance with Council
procedure rules I believe none have been
received
therefore will now go to mc2018 the
overview and scrutiny committee reports
and I'd like to invite councilor Wellen
to introduce paper MC 2018 which is for
noting
castlewellan
thank you chair
my report
mc2018 covers two meetings of the joint
overview and scrutiny committee
we reviewed the role of members
appointed by Council as representatives
to outside bodies
we looked at the value that the
representatives bring to the body and to
the council
each body was asked about their view on
the value of having a council member as
a member of that body
or as an observer
the draft minute is attached
as an appendix to that to report
mc2019 and the recommendations for
council's consideration are in that
report
members may find it more relevant to ask
questions on this topic during
consideration of that item the other
topic reviewed was the planning
enforcement transformation project
officers detailed
the um
the extensive work that they've been
carrying out on the project
they've been doing this despite the
covid restrictions
a new enforcement flowchart detailing
determining the many steps in the
process from initial reporting to final
outcome has been devised
this led to improved workflow management
and enabled staff to deal with high
personal workloads
including extra work
around the need for changes or
relaxation of planning restrictions to
enable businesses to comply with the
covid issues
committee agreed that a joint member
task and finish group be established to
make recommendations to a joint on a
joint local planning enforcement policy
and that progress on the transformation
be reviewed by The Joint overview and
scrutiny committee upon completion of
the work of the task and finish group
thank you chair I'm happy to answer
questions
thank you Council counselors do you have
any questions for Council well and
please use the handset facility
councilor Phil please
thank you yeah just uh confirm counselor
wellum uh I certainly know I'm sure a
number of other counselors do get
repeated questions about our performance
on on the um enforcement issues that uh
that there is a certain feeling abroad
that says we tend to comment and monitor
things but not take effective action did
your scrutiny meeting actually come to
the conclusion that that's unjust and
that our response is adequate
um yes I think we do I think one of one
of the problems is that there are a lot
of alleged breaches which are reported
and I think officers were uh of the view
that perhaps they're not quite as good
at passing on to others uh uh
information around alleged breaches
which are not planning issues
um and that has been tightened up
um
there was a an immense amount of work
um which had been sort of hanging around
for many years some of it and they have
they have reviewed uh every case that
has been outstanding for any time uh and
um I think they've reduced significantly
the number of outstanding cases and they
have a really good process now so that
every every case is captured and every
case is progressed
uh
when uh when there was the the first uh
stage of the reorganization of the
um enforcement team they found that
there were a number of uh cases well
there are a number of cases which were
uh given their own specific case number
but they were indeed the same alleged
breach
um but the process has been tightened up
and and everything seems to be working
much better
um officers
agree that there is still some way to go
um and that's why the task and finish
group is being set up and a report will
come back to overview and scrutiny in in
the future
thank you thank you councilor War boys
please
thank you chair
um councilor welcome on the uh flowchart
you described
from the planning enforcement is there a
space on that flowchart for feedback
from
um
about how the case was actually settled
to
um the complainant satisfaction or not
uh this this is this is a process that
is being looked at that
um I mean basically I think you're
talking about some sort of happy forms
whether or not the complainant felt that
the
um the case had been dealt with and had
come to a satisfactory conclusion that
is something which which if it isn't
being done satisfactory will be looked
at
thank you councilman
councilor Mansell please
uh thank you chair
um now we all know that enforcement is a
very public-facing part of the of the
district council's work
um and and I and I look forward to
seeing some improvement in the service
but one of the uh regular comments I
received from both members of the public
and uh parish councils is the fact that
it there doesn't seem to be as any uh
sensible time between before an
acknowledgment of any complainant you
know if they send something in uh they
don't seem to even get an acknowledgment
that it's been received so they don't
know if anything is happening on it I
mean I I won't make any comments about
the outcome of any planning enforcement
case because they're often the public
are not satisfied but that is just the
legal process but but I I am concerned
about the lack of acknowledgment of a
complaint being made to the council to
the person who's put that complaint in
well I think there is there is pretty
much an automatic
um acknowledgment
um but I think perhaps you're what
you're talking about is is there
feedback at the various stages
um my own personal uh um uh uh view is
that when whenever I have um uh
appreciate it may be different for
members but when I have
um uh put in an alleged breach our case
has been uh looked at I after
as soon as the uh site inspection has
taken place I have heard back now I
appreciate not every not every
enforcement case needs a site inspection
but
um if there if there are particular
cases I mean this is an ongoing process
so I I I believe it is getting better
but if there are ongoing problems then I
I think we at the overview of scrutiny
committee need to know about it and also
the task and finish group
uh thank you uh you know I I've not got
any issue with response to members it's
a response to the members of the public
uh and Parish councils that I'm
concerned about because if it's a if
it's an automatic acknowledgment I've
certainly had reports that they haven't
even had that so um I I do think that is
one area that does need to be looked at
um yeah I mean if I can come back I
think that I think I do believe that
every every alleged breach report gets
an an automatic feedback or gets a
letter to say that it has been logged
and there is a case officer
um the name and contact details are
there so if there is a problem then it
should be possible for the individual to
follow it up
well maybe I will pass on my comments uh
to you in another Forum like here
counselor
that would be really useful I think
don't lose that point so uh councilor
Norris please
thank you Mr chairman
uh as a review meeting approximately
five weeks or so ago on enforcement
um the possibility was discussed of a
regular update on open cases being
provided to members on a ward by Ward
basis was anything further mentioned in
that respect thank you
yes that that was mentioned the other
thing that was mentioned was that the
possibility that they well that they
would look into the possibility of
um some information being available to
members
um automatically via in the same sort of
way that you can find information about
planning applications
um progress that's being made with those
that progress being made with
um Enforcement cases might also be
available not necessarily to the public
but to members
thank you for that
thank you looks like we've come to the
end of questioning so uh councilor
Welling do you have anything else to add
uh now I've got nothing else to add
thank you chair thank you and that
report was for noting only and we're now
going to move on to agenda item 11 11
Alpha so recommendation cabinet
committees
um JC stroke 20 stroke three half year
reports on Treasury management 2020 to
2021 and I'd like to invite councilor
Muller to introduce paper JC 20 stroke
three and move the recommendations of
the agenda thank you very much thank you
very much chair
at its meeting on the 30th of November
2020 The Joint audit and standards
committee considered paper Jac stroke 20
stroke 3 the half year report on
Treasury management 2021. before I move
to the recommendations chair may I have
permission to read a short statement
thank you
this is the joint treasury management
report covering the position for the
first six months of the financial year
2020 2021 it provides details of
performance effects of decisions taken
during that period and confirms
compliance with the council's treasury
management policy
the report explains in more detail the
factors affecting the strategy and
activities including the regulatory
framework economic conditions interest
rate and liquidity risk
in a relatively short period since the
onset of the covid-19 pandemic in March
and the ensuing enforced lockdown in
many jurisdictions the global economic
Fallout has been sharp and large Market
reaction was extreme with large force
and equities corporate bond markets and
to some extent real estate echoing
lockdown induced paralysis and the
Uncharted challenges for government
business and individuals
the unemployment rate increased to 4.1
percent with an expected Peak when the
furlough scheme was due to finish at the
end of October of between 8 and 9
percent
this is now likely to be revised
following the extension of the scheme to
the 31st of March 2021.
interest rates remained at the record
low of 0.1 percent and the headline rate
of consumer price inflation fell to 0.2
percent year on year
more specifically for mid-suffolk
District Council One banking activities
undertaken were within the daily bank
account limits two mid-suffolk has
reduced overall debt by 17 million by
making repayments on long-term public
workload Public Works loan board loans
and replacing medium stroke longer term
local Authority loans with short-term
loans
three the council lend a further 1.6
million to cifco Limited four all
investment activities undertaken were in
accordance with the approved
counterparty list
five the council's investment activities
including average returns can be found
at appendix C of the report
six investment by the council and
funding Circle has reduced as
unallocated funds have been reclaimed
and existing loans repaid During the
period this was 53 000 of the 215 000
previously invested leaving a balance on
30th September of 162 000 and seven the
council is compliant with the upper
limits for interest rate exposure the
investment activity undertaken for the
year was done so in priority order of
security and liquidity over yield as
prescribed in the treasury management
strategy
um the recommendations set out in the
report were accepted by the committee on
on the 30th of November and there are
two recommendations 3.1 and 3.2 in your
papers and the recommendations are one
that the treasury management activity
for the first six months of the 2021 uh
period as set out in the report and
appendices to be noted and secondly that
it be noted that both council's treasury
management activity for the first six
months of 2021 was in accordance with
the approved treasury management
strategy and that the council has
complied with all the treasury
management indicators for this period if
any members have any questions uh that
the director of finances and Director of
Finance Catherine still is is here at
this meeting tonight but I'd like to
propose those recommendations and could
I answer a second to please thank you
chair thank you councilman do we have a
second there
counselor Caston
thank you very much yes I'd like to
Second councilman's proposal
thank you uh we're now going to move on
to questions and counselors may ask as
many questions they wish however I keep
saying this so please listen they must
be relevant and they must be to do with
the subject so please think about your
question pose it correctly and I'm sure
you'll then get a clear and concise
answer so uh let's go for it councilor
Mathison
thank you Chad
um on
draw members attention to page 45 of the
of the council papers which is part of
the this uh this report one of the
appendix B I think we'll see
um the
it's clearance in from various figures
that the
um the borrowing requirements in
relation to sifco and Gateway 14 are are
very large
um in relation to our other activities
outside of the um housing revenue
account of course and
um
noting that the the changes
the the government to bring in relation
to Public Works loan board
um
if if we are going to continue to
invest uh with sifco
um is this going to jeopardize our
ability to borrow for the housing
revenue account in order to build and
buy more Council houses
thank you councilman could I ask the
Assistant Director of Finance Catherine
Steele to answer councilor mathison's
question please thank you and uh and
please use um Catherine still as often
as you like because I know this is a
complex subject that requires the right
answers thank you chairman
Catherine thank you chair yeah thank you
councilor Mathison for that uh question
uh just to clarify
um the loans that have been taken out
for sifco will be finished in this
financial year so we're anticipating we
will be at the full 50 million pound
investment for sifco by the end of March
2021.
so moving into next financial year which
is when we need to take out more
borrowing in terms of Gateway 14 and a
Housing Development then this won't
jeopardize our ability to access the
pwlb
um Gateway 14 is a development site
regeneration economic regeneration site
so that is eligible under the the new
guidelines from pwlb as well as our
housing developments thank you
thank you Catherine
um councilor Matheson do you have a
supplementary question just
um yes I I think the the the question
that that raises really is
um if we
don't find a suitable property in the
next few weeks which sifco wants to buy
um what will we then do
and what will be the the future strategy
for for sithco
and funding sifco
Catherine that's quite an in-depth
question so it just needs a short answer
please
I'll try and make it as short as I can
um the funding for the end of March if
it's not all completed by 15 million
then we won't carry it forward so this
is in in essence the last few weeks that
we're able to invest in in sifco so say
that will be the end of it so if we're
not up to full capacity we won't do
anything in 21 22.
thank you for that
thank you moving on councilor mantle
please
uh thank you chair
um again I'm also referring to page 45
of our Council papers uh paragraph 2.3
and I would just like
um to have some clarity clarity about
um the proposed says there are proposals
to allow authorities that are not
involved in debt for yield activity to
borrow at lower rates
um can somebody tell me whether that
applies to us does that mean because we
are
um involved in debt for yield activity
we will not be able to borrow at the
lower rates proposed by this new
arrangement
Catherine
thank you chair
um we will be able to access pwlb
because the conditions of pwlb is that
it's forward-looking so as we move into
2122 we won't have anything in our
Capital program that would be deemed as
debt for yield so we would have access
to the lower rate pwlb rates were
dropped by one percent when the
announcement was made about the new the
new lending terms so that's what we
would be able to access
could I just come back so that that that
operates on a sort of year by year basis
that we don't look back uh it's within
within Financial if we're looking
towards the financial year 2122 if we
don't do any debt for yield activities
at all in that year we can have the
lower rates is that am I reading that
correctly
yes and it's actually three-year forward
look rather than just the one year so it
would be 21 22 22 23 and 23 24.
thank you and uh councilor feel please
had her hand up before me but uh okay
um
just a quick one please on the uh
looking at the uh Stroud of fans
performance
I note that the investment amount is two
million pounds the investment valuation
is 1.2 million
to 800 000 less and the cumulative net
interest is 500 000 pounds am I
understanding that correctly do you
think or is that wrong uh so that's the
first point and then I had something on
page 52 which is uh one 1.16 parallel
116 the um
uh talk about the standard for pooled
funds and the way that has to be carried
into the expenditure statement uh not
until
um 23 24 but I wonder whether that is a
matter of concern for the future it's
not that far away
thank you cash the field
thank you yes I can answer those
um yes you were reading the the table on
page 52 you're talking about the
Schroeder investment uh yes the the
amount invested was two million pounds
and as at the 30th of September the
current valuation was 1.2 million pounds
because obviously
um markets dropped a lot uh in the first
half of the year due to the covered
pandemic I haven't got the most
up-to-date figures but I wouldn't be
surprised if that valuation has gone up
again since then and yes the the
cumulative interest that we've received
right back to when we first invested in
in Schroeders is the the 0.5 million
that you referred to
um and in terms of the other question
you asked about the the accounting
change
um it's something for us to keep an eye
on because the government has said it's
not eligible until April 23 but they
quite often extend deadlines and change
the arrangements around that so it's
something that we will definitely be
keeping an eye on
that if I may come back on that does
that mean that the the things the issues
that we might look for now like the
Shroud is one I just identified are a
potential problem or are they not
um depending on the market valuation as
at that date when it comes in if it was
still below Market if the market
valuation was still below the investment
price then yes we would need to take
something into into our general fund
and these are short-term Investments
unlike our cifco where we sort of claim
we're going to hold the Investments
until until the property values rise and
some number of years these are
relatively short-term I assume uh
Schroeders is for the longer term you
know it's cash that we thought we had
for a longer period of time but there is
a you know we can reclaim that the funds
if we need to so so we will keep that
position under review over the next two
years
thank you
thank you before I move on to Council of
eBay and that's just you might have a
handset to tell me off actually because
um I made a terrible mistake and I
forgot to get the second day prior to
the questions so please accept my
apologies on that is my excitement to
get moving on to the questions
um therefore can I have a second to
please and I'll come back to you shortly
councilor even okay secondary is uh
councilor
thank you very much happy to second
thank you councilor eberne please
thank you very much chair um and thanks
to councilor Miller for your paper and
also Catherine for the questions you've
answered so far
um appendix B um page 45
um paragraph 2.2
um refers to the lower housing rate that
is available
um can you confirm that or can ask
whether we've um reviewed our housing
Ambitions in the light of that lower
rate available and and if not whether we
can take advantage of that
um sooner rather than later especially
to progress some more environmentally
sustainable housing thank you
or or Catherine actually whoever's best
qualified to answer that Catherine
collection
uh I was gonna say I might be qualified
to answer answer the financial part of
it I'm not sure I can in terms of the
ambition around around housing
um yes we would be able to access that
rate for for housing and uh certainly in
terms of the housing revenue account uh
I know assistant director for housing is
looking at reviewing the housing the
30-year housing business plan at the
moment so that will include uh details
and sort of our ambition around house
building moving forward
okay thanks very much I'll follow up
with him thank you thank you uh
councilor mathiasm please thank you
um page 34 paragraph uh 11.
um it's very welcome that we will start
to receive the um the reports on the
environmental social and governance
performance of our various Investments
and I was wondering whether
um Catherine Steele is able to
confirm that the returns that we will
receive will be broadly similar to those
that we receive at the moment
Catherine please
we haven't changed anything yet as a
result of the environmental social and
governance report that we've had from
Ireland close and that's mainly for one
of the reasons one of the other
questions about the market valuation
currently being below what we took the
Investments out at so until we get to
the point where we wouldn't lose money
by changing our investments we will hold
those but certainly considering and
looking at where we might invest in the
future
yeah yeah I see the I think what I'm
what I'm asking really is is
um you know do we know
if if the the alternative with with ESG
filtering is going to
um you know it's performing broadly
similarly granted that they've all gone
down a bit with the market
um are they performing similarly I think
is the question and obviously I'm
looking ahead to discussing this at the
old standards committee on Monday
apologies Council I didn't quite
understand the question we haven't done
that direct comparison at this point in
time so um I couldn't kind of answer
that question now
okay well I'll I'll ask it again on
Monday in a different context then thank
you
brilliant thank you I can see no more
hands up so we're now going to move to
debate and uh just a reminder that
councilors will only be allowed three
minutes and this will be timed and you
can only speak once please use the hands
up facility to indicate you wish to
start the debate
anybody
Abram counselor Stringer please
uh thank you chair uh and happy New Year
to you
um and to you all uh the motion on the
debate uh just asks us to note all of
the indicators and that we have
conducted our activities within line
with them and of course the paper
demonstrates on both those items we
clearly have
however I would like to make some
comment uh I'll be voting for this paper
uh I said but it will be under somewhat
protest because some of the indicators
in there we would seek to change uh
because we think they're they're
detrimental to our communities and some
of the activity wrapped up in this
report also I would just like to briefly
comment on
I have to say as us rushing to make sure
that we've invested as much as we can of
the borrowed money into sifco before the
government shuts the door I have to say
is is is a step too far for me and
should not be encouraged with the
indicators that we've set
we must be the only people that are
rushing to buy a house while it's still
burning uh
the other thing that we have issues with
are some of the Investments that we
choose to to to partner and to promote
we we have clear policies that try and
maximize Community Health and resilience
yet we invest in things like tobacco uh
we really really have to review where
we're going with this so we align our
treasury management indicators also with
the desires of our community thank you
for being able to speak to you
thank you and that's all noted uh
councilor mayor please
thank you chair um I'd like to just
respond to the last comment made by uh
Council Stringer Rhys IFCO
um and reassure him really that the ZIP
code board is not rushing to spend money
it is looking to invest but it is
maintaining the very high standards of
um governments that it's employed
throughout the program to ensure only
um
suitable properties are purchased and I
was very interested to hear his comment
um that were house is burning well sifco
in the last quarter has repaid all its
debt to all the the costly debt
um we paid it fully to the council
um
Capital values have started to rise the
percentage of rent paid has I think a
percentage recovered I think is
increasing and voids are falling and
this is all against the background where
we've been through apparently the worst
downturn for 300 years
and it's interesting to note that cifco
is providing positive cash flow to the
council when other Investments such as
the Schroeder Investments are failing
um really quite badly so I think sifco
is performing and the house is
definitely not on fire thank you
thank you that's glad to I'm glad to
know that uh councilor Passmore please
uh thank you very much chairman just
just a couple of comments um really
picking up on Andrew's point about
looking at our investments I think
what's just been Illustrated tonight is
actually it does pay to have a variety
of investments in order to spread the
risk I have no problem at all in once
again looking at our investments I can
remember years ago when I was leader
some of you will remember I think you
were there well you must have been there
but at the same time Andrew when we had
some councils investing in things like
egg Iceland and God knows what else
which really
um ended up as a bit of a disaster so
what I'm saying is we learn the lessons
we move forwards so looking at this is
absolutely fine and when you're looking
at ethical Investments I can remember
people put things into the then
different or what has now had to change
radically the co-op bank and so on so
all I'm saying is have a look at this by
all means I I would support that but we
need to look at good returns to the
taxpayers balanced with ethics and
whilst we're at it supporting the local
economy and you know I'm very passionate
about that so um I just wanted to add
that to the to the debate as we go
forward as a good idea and I will be of
course supporting um the recommendation
thank you very much chairman
thank you
anybody else wish to enter the debate uh
councilor field
um your hands gone down now do you wish
to enter the debate
I do
just a slight trouble with the clicking
on hands thank you yes it's really the
issue again of um as Council plasma just
said he he supports local investment and
uh we would certainly support local
investment in some some items
um we are very much concerned always
that the investment for Cisco is across
the country in all sorts of places
in a variety of a diverse variety of
operations which one understands
um the problem is that all these
locations are within the same
economy the UK economy and clearly a
number of them are quite challenged at
the moment I think the news today if I
remember it indicated a number of large
companies pulling out of office
accommodation having discovered that
people can work from home so our
concerned very much is that there is a
very substantial risk here I don't know
who has a comparison of the say the ccla
investment which is small but but
compared with the the cifco yield to me
it looked quite sound and somewhat
surprisingly as a body they seem that
even their property fund seems to be
doing well at the moment so I think we
have a what I regard as a reasoned
concern about this and the level of risk
that's involved
irrespective of current performance
thank you
thank you I'll just give you a couple of
seconds to see if anybody else wants to
earn to the debate
no all quite okay uh councilor do you
wish to add anything
no I'm quite happy with with the all the
answers that um the assistant director
for finance has given and thank you to
members who've actually asked questions
both these questions and in the debate
thank you chair thank you uh therefore
before we move to the vote I'll just
read out the recommendation
um one that the treasury management
activity the first six months of 2020
2021 are set out and report and
appendices be noted two that it be noted
at both councils treasury management
activity for the first six months of 20
20 21 was in accordance with the
approved treasury management strategy
and that the council has complied with
all the treasury management indicators
during this period
announce the corporate manager
governance and Civic office to conduct
the electronic vote
thank you chair cancers can you please
open the vote
call that by clicking the plus sign in
top right hand of the agenda screen and
selecting attendance and voting the vote
for the up this item will show in blue
but you may need to scroll down the page
to be able to open the vote thank you
okay um we need to take the following
three votes verbally councilor Humphries
four
councilor War boys
for and councilor Phillips four thank
you
okay so that is
foreign
against and four abstentions thank you
that is carried moving on to agenda 11b
which is mc20 stroke 19 recommendations
from the joints overview and scrutiny
committee I refer you to the additional
recommendation in the table papers and
I'd like to invite counselor Wellen to
introduce paper mc20 stroke 19 and move
the recommendations in a report and in
the table papers
thank you Chad yeah I'm pleased to
present the recommendations from The
Joint overview excuse scrutiny meeting
on the 23rd of November and the
additional recommendation from the
mid-suffolk overview of scrutiny meeting
on the 14th of January
this can be found as you said chair in
the tabled papers
it should be remembered that it is a
full council meeting that these
appointments are made usually at the
annual meeting and usually for one year
there is little or no debate about the
appointments and little feedback from
those appointed during their time
representing the council
there are six recommendations from the
overview and scrutiny meeting on the
23rd of November and a further one from
the meeting on the 14th of January
uh if I I'd like to just say a few words
about each of them in turn if I may
um 1.1
uh overview of scrutiny recommend that
there be no further appointments to the
Joint Waste Management board or the
Suffolk joint emergency planning policy
panel as these bodies no longer meet
um 1.2 the representative of mid-suffolk
District Council councilor Brewster said
at the overview of security meeting that
the Haven Gateway partnership is no
longer relevant and attendance is of no
value to our Council it's recommended
therefore that Midsouth withdrawal from
the Partnerships
uh at 1.3
we heard from The Observer appointed by
by baber District Council to represent
that council at Sudbury citizens advice
that attendance is of value to that body
and to the council
councilor Osborne attends as an observer
and is not a trustee of that body
1.4 we recommend a process for reporting
back by Representatives appointed to
outside bodies to enable joint overview
of scrutiny to review member
representation on an annual basis
1.5 is a recommendation that support
support and training be given to
Representatives particularly when
they're first appointed
training is sometimes given by the body
but it is important that the
representatives are supported in the
roles to which they have been appointed
1.6
this Council has made the appointment of
a representative to the East-West rail
Consortium but that counselor does not
attend meetings or have any input into
the Consortium because the council does
not pay the required subscription
at a time when it's essential that fewer
Journeys are taken by Road and improved
rail service connecting Suffolk to the
Midlands and Beyond is needed
there are four Rail stations in
mid-suffolk it is vital that mid-suffer
District Council are represented at
meetings when the East-West route
through mid-suffer is discussed and
decisions taken
overview of scrutiny recommend that the
council considers paying the
subscription so that our representative
May attend
and the additional recommendation is
that Council approaches the Suffolk
disabilities Forum to establish whether
representation on the body is
appropriate and if so that's an
appointment be made by full Council
and I I will therefore propose all of
those I think it's seven separate
recommendations and look for a seconder
thank you councilor Willem do you have a
second to please
counselor Brewster
I'm sorry Mr chair
um my hand actually wasn't up I was just
getting ready for a comment on 1.2 okay
so I wasn't second in this one uh and
then I'll go down to next enlist which
is counselor EK pen young please
uh thank you Mr chairman um I thought
that we were going to be taking these
recommendations uh not on block so uh
Council no
um are you seconding the proposal that's
been put forward
not at the moment okay so uh councilor
mathiason are you seconding that was my
plan yes I seconded uh yes thank you
perfect thank you very much okay so
um
we have the second day uh we'll now move
into questions and again just a reminder
um you can ask as many questions as you
like but you must make sure that it is a
question to the point and relevant to
the uh to the article that we're
discussing so um if I go in line let's
look at councilor Brewster first please
um
yeah I I would like to do an explanation
really Mr chair so that probably comes
in debate I suspect but um
or if you wish me to do it now because
the the the the thing on Haven Gateway
has changed a little bit since I
reported to the overview in scrutiny and
it's just changed in this last couple of
weeks
come here
right finally managed to get off mute no
I don't wish to do that thanks
councilman will stick to questions uh
and debate will be at debates and uh I'm
sure what you uh are going to discuss
will be important at that at that stage
so moving on then uh councilor field
thank you the first question is is well
there's two two or three questions
um the first one is really that uh where
is the list that Council Wellen was
reading from because I'm looking
currently at page
73 and that has some paragraphs labeled
1.3 1.4 1.5
but during that text for instance it
repeatedly states that Council wellon
proposed recommendation 1.1 which was
set into our counter scarf yeah uh we'll
answer the question I think you should
be on page 63 is that correct councilor
Willem it is yes what you're looking at
councilor field is is the the debate at
overview of scrutiny and how these
recommendations
materialized towards the end of that
debate but this specific recommendations
are on page 63 and 64 and in the tabled
paper
right
I think I'll return we're returning the
rest perhaps first divides yes no
problem custom answer please
uh thank you chair
um I have one simple question to ask
um but my other question uh may be a bit
um I'm not really sure if it is debate
or not my my simple question is
um how much is the subscription fee for
the East West rail Consortium that is a
very simple question with hopefully a
very simple answer my other question is
that
um maybe this isn't a question I just
don't feel able to
um debate and or vote on these
particular recommendations on block
because
some of them are for consideration and
some of them are actual recommendations
and I would like to know why some of
them are that we we the council consider
things whereas other things are just
plain recommendations
if that is a question okay so I'll
probably come back to that to you on
debate because I hear where you're
coming from and I get it completely but
I'll have to listen to debate to whether
we're going to do that or not and that's
the due process so let's answer the
question on the the fee councilwale uh
sorry I don't I don't have that thing
there's something 1500 pounds I believe
is that correct fifteen hundred pounds
yeah 200 pounds yeah thank you
again I'm not being disrespectful for
you we will leave that to a debate and
I'll consider everything that I listen
to throughout the debate and decide
which way we go at that point
um councilor Passmore please can I just
come back certainly on those on those
recommendations that that tame the word
consider
are we actually going to be making a
decision tonight or not because I don't
really understand the word consider
if I if I can help the the word consider
has been used when
um uh an appointment has been agreed at
the start of the year
um and we're asking we're asking the
council review the uh consider again for
instance the
um what was the point of appointing
somebody to the Joint Waste Management
board when it no longer existed so
um and and and then we've got that um we
didn't appoint somebody to the
mid-suffolk district council uh sorry to
the uh citizens advice
um there are reasons given why we
shouldn't but we want it obviously felt
that that should be considered it should
be discussed by Council it just wasn't
discussed but then there are new there
are new suggestions being put forward
like the reporting mechanism so that
that's why that is not for consideration
but that it should be set out and that
would report to
um the overview of scrutiny committee
I I think it's a fair answer and I think
the word consider when you read the
article is is appropriate to be honest
with you moving on uh councilor Passmore
thank you very much chairman it sounds a
bit like a Yes Minister answer
appointing someone to a board that
doesn't exist but there we go
um I I too would like to ask you to
consider no pun intended uh Sarah by the
way
um whether you would take these
separately because
um there are differences there and I
think it's very important that my
question also was going to be so that
was the first one and your chairmanship
skills will now come to No Doubt come to
the fore does anybody have a rough idea
of how much we pay to The Haven Gateway
please
a year but that is a little while ago so
okay we'll um we'll take that side too
I'll get the offices working on that and
see if we can get the answer for you and
if it comes up at the debate stage I'll
bring it in there yeah that's right
thank you very much
okay uh chair can I just come back why
why why did why are we taking them all
together or should we be taking them
separately uh uh just just to make it
easier to save me having to
um go through and propose seven
different recommendations and look for
seven different uh second as it was felt
appropriate to ask for to to propose the
lot in one go and end us together second
that for all of them in one go but I
think I think those who have spoken are
are right that we should take them one
at a time because they are quite
different
and that was my intention that they
would be taking one at a time good I'm
happy with that as you're the proposer I
get it I get the drift I know where
people are coming from and I can pick up
the tone already
um I'm still gonna go for the um the
proposal and a second for the whole
amount yeah I think we'll take them
separately and this is my my suggestion
to you
um before we go to the debate and that
suggestion is that we take
recommendations 1.1 1.4
1.5 and 1.6 collectively
because I don't see that being a major
issue and then we look at 1.2 and then
1.3 individually
are you happy with that as the proposer
and 1.7 as well oh sorry the the extra
one I've called it 1.7 it's the the one
on the table page table papers
yep okay happy would have to be taken
separately I think yeah I I agree
um can I can I second that Arrangement
yeah I was going to come to you in a
second
so I'm happy with that and that's the
way we're going to proceed as long as
you're the proposal are also content
yes and yes the math as soon as the
second day yes
um chair um
there may be there may be more debate on
1.6 and then there may be those who
would wish to support 1.1 1.4 1.5
um but not 1.6 let's let's see how we go
let's see how we go all right
is everybody happy so far yes we're now
going to stay on there on questions so
uh councilor Whitehead please
uh thank you chair I I understand that
councilor Brewster is our present
representative on the Haven Gateway
partnership and I'd like to ask the
question what might have happened in the
last couple of weeks that might have
changed his opinion
on that recommendation
yeah
um
yes I reported to overview in scrutiny
and I gave my
thoughts at that time
um in the last week or two there has
been a change in the
um approach really in that
um
Haven Gateway partnership are working
with the port system and with the
Freeport systems and the structures that
are being made there
um they could be very very useful to
mid-suffolk as far as Gateway 14 is
concerned which would bring obviously
some
really positive elements in into that
structure which could support all the
businesses on their rate systems on the
business rate systems that's not my
reason which I would I would now like to
um with withdraw that from from what's
in the recommendations
thank you
Joe I don't know how we withdraw
something from the recommendation no I
think the only way to to for that not to
be approved is for it to be
rejected yes
you're not playing a guessing game here
or who knows more
um we're going to bring in the um the
officer which is Emily Ewell to answer
that question directly Emily please
thank you chair just to confirm because
these are the recommendations of the
committee no individual counselor can
amend them so the way to deal with it is
to either vote for or if you're in
disagreement with the recommendation to
vote against it in its entirety thank
you chair
thank you everybody happy with that and
I do have an answer to the cost uh Haven
Gateway five thousand pounds thank you
perfect
there comes to Whitehead have you
complete your questions
sorry I'll take my hand down thank you
thank you Matheson please
on the tabled paper
um which we think we're calling
recommendations at 1.7
um does this actually refer to the
mid-suffolk disabilities Forum or or is
there another body which is Suffolk wide
cancer well in place uh chair there is
there is a body that is suffered wide
but
um since this recommendation was first
made we have found that the more
appropriate our body possibly would be
the mid-suffolk
um disabilities Forum
um but I I can't change that
after the overview of security committee
have
proposed that this and and have agreed
that this be recommended to council so I
think we we stick with this because it
does say that we approach the Suffolk
disabilities Forum if in doing that they
say it would be more appropriate to be
represented on the mid suffer
disabilities Forum then we will bring
that back
it seems a very good way forward thank
you
thank you councilor Mansell please
sorry to come back thank you for that
allow me to come back uh uh chair but I
I'm still a little bit confused by the
wording of the proposals
um if we just think uh for instance the
one we've just been talking about to do
with councilor Brewster and and he he's
changing what he was going to say but
the actual uh recommendation is that the
the council consider withdrawal from The
Haven Gateway partnership now if I vote
for that does that mean I want to
withdraw from The Haven Gateway
partnership or I want to consider
withdrawing from The Haven Gateway
partnership
um and similarly if I want to vote
against am I saying yeah we should keep
carry on with the Haven Gateway
partnership or no we shouldn't even
consider it I'm sorry if I'm being
pedantic but I am quite worried about
the wording of this no you're not being
pedantic and it's right to question
um I believe and I'm going to get Emily
yours to come in anyway that consider
means exactly that if you vote for then
your Senate council should consider it
not not consider it
could I come back there and say how are
the councils considering it if we're not
considering it today while we're in full
Council how do we as a council consider
it if we don't actually debate whether
or not to withdraw really to my mind I
would be happier if it said that um the
recommendation was that the council
withdrew from The Haven Gateway
partnership and then it will be a nice
simple yes I agree with withdrawing or
no I don't think we should withdraw but
this considering are we in the process
of setting up a working group to do all
this considering or are we as a whole
Council doing the considering here where
you're coming from and very good points
uh Emily please
thank you chairman the leader actually
determines the proposals for outside
bodies and and puts those forward as
recommendations to the council and this
obviously normally happens at annual
Council so the wording of the motion is
essentially for the uh the councils to
either
um ask the leader to consider
withdrawing from The Haven Gateway
partnership or effectively don't
consider it so stay in the Haven Gateway
partnership so you're not making a
decision to withdraw tonight if the
council um was in favor of that
recommendation they would essentially be
giving a steer to the leader to consider
withdrawing and not putting a
representative forward I hope that helps
to explain quite a complex complexly
worded recommendation chair
can I just thank
um Emily for that um but so so
effectively you're telling me that
whichever way I vote on on number 1.2
um I I really don't have any say in the
matter because it's all down to the
leader
I think um I think she's actually
explained it quite well and we're going
to be talking all night about this
um to me it's fairly clear consider
means exactly that and it allows them to
go and consider it whether they go for
it or not um we are going to move on
um so counselor Autumn please
well I'm sorry chairman
but
that doesn't explain how it leads the
council so if it is for the leader to
consider
then we are giving her that whoever the
leader is that decision
so
there's the same point I'll come back to
Emilio so will we be told tonight
whether the leader will actually
withdraw from each of those
um draw the council from each of those
outside bodies or not as I said a pretty
similar question I'll go back to Emily
ill
Emily thank you chairman and my
apologies I left one step out of the
approvals process in terms of
appointments to outside bodies
once the leader makes a recommendation
it does have to come to the full Council
to be agreed so if you make this uh
decision today the leader would then
consider it and bring it back to a
future meeting of the council to be
agreed
right right
good okay seems a very
[Music]
um
bureaucratic bureaucratic way of dealing
with things but it's the way it is uh
councilor and uh yeah the question has
been answered do you have any other
questions
thank you councilor Phil please
the obvious question is if that is the
case one of the Dickens is this paper
before us tonight
you know if the leader makes the
decision then surely to God scrutiny
should have referred this to the leader
in in the same way as I do at the County
Council and the leader makes the
decision and then it comes to this body
it seems a nonsense but I guess we'll go
along with it otherwise as you point out
we'll talk all night yeah absolutely
right so getting back onto questions
councilor Mellon
uh sorry counselor Carter I didn't see
that I'm sorry cancel the cast please
oh thank you and I do apologize about
any uh background noise that may be
coming through from my daughter at the
moment
um just a quick query I
say if this is going through to you
consider if if the chair
um chooses not to consider this is this
then feedback or is it just left as um
uh because this is only going back to us
if it's been considered if it's chosen
not to be considered do we hear back
from it and do we get reasons why
foreign
please
uh terrify May the um it will be evident
with when a recommendation comes back or
not to the full Council to appoint
somebody to that body
I think that's the simplest way to to
answer that question yeah
because Carter happy
[Music]
I accept the answer it's just not yeah
it's a it's a wonderful way of doing
things
uh councilor Whitehead please
just posed the question isn't the point
of this being brought to council to get
a steer on this and the only way to get
a steer on it is to ask have a vote
because we can have a debate unless you
have a vote you can't really get a clear
steer
exactly exactly it's the way people read
things we're all different we all read
things differently and we all understand
things in different ways I'm not being
simplistic on this that's the way it is
I think uh Emily Ewell has answered most
of the questions and doubts that we had
and a thanker for input on this uh it's
more than welcome Council Whitehead do
you have any further questions
no just a bit slow get my hand down
again no problem
um so there are no more questions and um
we'll now move into debate although it
probably feels in fact councilor otton
are you asking the question
um no we're if we're into debate we will
be in a second so moving into debate
um although it feels like we've been in
the debates you'll be allowed three
minutes and you can speak once and this
will be timed so councilor Alton will
start with you please thank you very
much
um well I certainly will hope that the
um leader will make a recommendation
that this mid-suffolk District Council
continues to have a an observer on the
citizens advice Bureau
particularly at this time when so many
people are having to use their services
for advice on things like applying for
Universal Credit Etc so many people now
are faced a situation which they've
maybe never have been in before so I
really hope that she will do do so
um and I also think that this Council
needs some representation on the
East-West rail Consortium as has already
been said we have numerous
um uh Railway stations in the
mid-suffolk area and I know and I in
particular particularly concerned about
um Thurston where we are desperately
trying and mid-suffolk has used some
seal money
to try and get network rail to come up
with a proposal for making the crossing
there at Thurston railway station
um safe so I think it is extremely
important that this Council
who is already having discussions with
network rail are involved thank you
chairman
foreign
[Music]
thank you very much chairman yeah I just
wanted to comment regarding the Haven
Gateway in particular and to support
what Gerard Brewster has said because I
was a meeting the other day in fact we
were both at it and this concept of the
three three ports not the three ports
three ports I think this will be a
unique opportunity for for Suffolk as a
whole and certainly for mid-suffolk if
we are able to get a free Port based
both at felixstowe and Harwich I think
it's going in as one combined
application and that's unusual but we
need to be thinking about um the ports
there is a gateway
um without a debate starting but a
global Britain and reaching out to the
rest of the world and connecting and I'm
not really making a political point
there it's about how can we do that and
one of the great things about Felix
though which is our largest container
port in the country and Hampshire is
expanding as well is reaching out to
other parts of the United Kingdom
particularly a in the Midlands and the
Northern parts of the country and Wales
and it's really important we do that
because the extra benefits we could get
for the economy and growth here which we
all need done in the right way I think
is crucial and if we are talking about
spending five thousand pound notes on
being a member of The Haven Gateway it
will have lobbying powers and effect and
I think we need to do everything
possible to support it and I think it
was Gerald was saying the implications
for Gateway 14 could be quite profound I
think in the longer term we'll all
benefit from that so I actually think we
should
um maintain our membership of that and
I'm not going to get in the tangle about
whether I consider the consideration to
be considered that would be a
considerable amount of debate but
it is an important issue as regardless
of citizens advice Bureau as an observer
well uh I don't know whether we actually
need to have an observer I do think it's
a wonderful organization it does a huge
amount to help people in difficulty
throughout um large parts of mid-suffolk
but I do believe there are is it officer
present I think we do are represented
there and so on so I'm I'm not over
bothered about having additional
representation it's about adding value
but I would not want anyone to think I
wasn't very very supportive of the
citizens advice Bureau because I Johnny
Willem thank you very much chairman
thank you councilor Mansell please
uh thank you chair
um firstly I'd like to to make a comment
on
um that there seemed to be in the
previous discussion some um talk about
uh do whether to do some of these on
block or not
um and I believe if I've got it written
down correctly uh 1.1 1.4 1.5 1.6 and
1.7 you are going to take on block I
would prefer to remove 1.6 from that
block because I think that's a different
proposition certainly from 1.4 1.5
um uh because a has got the word
considering but I won't go there again
um
um but I I still I'm struggling with
that um but I because I would like to
say that um with regards to uh one point
uh uh 1.3 about the citizens advice
Bureau
um I do think it would be very
beneficial for the council to have an
observer uh we do um provide some funds
for the citizens device uh and I and I
see that a member represent rents is
very different from an officer
representative
um if all we are is an observer we don't
have voting Powers but I do think it
will provide a very good link between
citizens advice and the council uh on
the
um question of the is east west rail
Consortium I very much share councilor
ottens views that we do have the railway
line
um running through the um through our
district with a number of stations on
the line
um and anything that happens on that um
on that rail line uh does have a huge um
impact on some of our communities
certainly my own Community where we have
the main road um crossing the railway
line any um you know albeit is wonderful
to have more trains on a line whether
they're Freight or passenger trains but
we do also have the consequence of um a
roadblock more often so um I you know
there are certain parts of our district
which are very much affected by that
Railway line and I think it is a vital
um for us to have a representative on
that body thank you thank you and I've
listened to your um points on the way in
which we're going to vote on this and
I'll consider it as we move forward
please
thank you chair yes um my preference
would be actually be for individual
votes I know it's under this system it's
such a difficult way to do it but it
does give members the most flexibility
because clearly members have got very
great difficulties with it
um I'd like to speak in favor of the 1.3
which is the Observer status at The
District Council and give you some
reasons why I think that we we should
actually have one
um Council Osborne from baber District
Council who's their Vice chair of ons
um is their Observer and he did at the
committee
um elaborate on how successful it was
for him to be an observer an observer of
course doesn't have a vote they are not
a full trustee but I think it would be
very useful to have an observer in an
earlier meeting this afternoon in
conjunction with the relief trust in
Stone Market which I'm a trustee there
were issues raised by cab which were of
great concern to me and didn't appear to
have been addressed by offices
in the positive therefore I think an
observer as a counselor would be
extremely useful they can they can
address the Board of Trustees but they
take no part in the actual
decision-making process and therefore
there is clearly no conflict of interest
um so I think that would be very useful
and it's not continuing an observer as
councilor Otten said it's actually
bringing the Observer back to uh the
mid-suffic cab on the Haven Gateway
partnership I'm very pleased that
councilor Brewster has got new
information uh following the scrutiny
committee and I would be very supportive
of rejoining that but I would say
um if we were a member of an
organization at the Hayden Gateway
partnership before and in order to fully
participate why didn't we pay the
subscription then because we've sort of
disenfranchised ourselves by not paying
but I would support rejoining the Haven
Gateway partnership thank you
thank you
um councilor custom please
thank you very much Mr chairman so I'm a
member of the ovian scrutiny committee
um and um during this meeting we
discussed um at one point too that
Haven's Gateway partnership and
um it it came up that it wasn't good
value for money since then
we've um had a um update on it and I
think if I was in that meeting now and
um councilor Brewster was telling me
what his update I wouldn't have made the
decision that I made to agree with that
I think that that does change things
ever such a lot
um the original decision was down to is
it good value for money
um is it necessary is it does it bring a
benefit to the council and um yes that
that's changed greatly
um the and 1.3
um I I wasn't keen on it at the time I
didn't um vote for it I don't think it's
necessary I think we'd have enough
information comes in from there
um and I haven't really changed my mind
on that
but um I'll I'll listen to the um debate
thank you
thank you uh councilor Miller please
thank you chair
um I I also um cannot support item 1.3
um I am a trustee at Mid Suffolk cab I
wasn't appointed by Midsouth District
Council but I was appointed when I first
joined Stone Market Town Council back in
2015.
um we also have representation from
Suffolk County Council by by way of
councilor gowley and I generally
honestly believe there is no need for an
observer
um to join that meeting as well thank
you chair
thank you counselor
field please
thank you I'll consider being brief
uh I think the
Haven Gateway partnership we are talking
about a very substantial organization
um with a vast percentage of suffolks
GDP and it would be wise to stay
associated with that
it's a small sum of money you know
one of us could give his locality budget
to if it was that desperately short of
cash in the council
um on these citizens advice Bureau it
what one takes the point that we don't
want too many representatives there but
but it clearly is an organization which
provides very substantial support for a
large number of our population people
who need advice of various types it
saves a small fortune in giving people
debt advice of various types it seems
like something that we should maintain a
really close link to
um and I would have thought the cost of
that is
very small and therefore an observer is
a useful investment
on the reporting template no one's
mentioned that I'm never too fond of
templates they went out when one had
quill pens and but nevertheless it's
clear that we need proper reports from
people who do take part in these
meetings to ensure that all counselors
are kept informed the format should be
in my view electronic and easy to access
training uh
to be established again is a given I
would have thought and that's um there
on the considering an appointment for
the East-West rail Consortium my view of
that argument again is that the body has
influence on the railway which is uh
vital to our sustainable transport in an
East-West Direction and pretty vital to
fight transport from from felixstow Port
the sum of money involved is small and
the potential yield is quite high if it
influences the work at Thurston for
instance just slightly we're talking
about a million pound project that you
might or may not deliver the same issue
was needed Market railway station where
there are a large
sums of money concerned for relatively
small investment so I'm in favor of all
those and uh the one I can't see I'll be
in favor of that as well thank you
[Music]
thank you moving on to council please
uh thank you chairman um I think that um
uh councilor Phil has actually just
touched on the subject I was going to
raise which is one of the considerations
we had at the overview and security
committee was the fact that we didn't
have a mechanism for observers and
representatives to report back to
council which we thought was actually
um vital there was really no point in
having these observers and
representatives if we didn't get
information back to council that we can
then discuss and review and continue to
see whether there's value in that
process
um you know from the point of view of
the different recommendations I think
clearly with the Haven Gateway
partnership the information that has
come to the fore now would would not
would basically have meant that we
wouldn't have been making the
recommendation in the way that we have
and I think it's from an economic point
of view as councilor Passmore has said I
think we definitely need to be to be
there and I think that just to a large
extent the same goes for
recommendation 1.6 regarding the East
well East
West rail Consortium because again I I
hear the the comment about
sustainability but there's also a I
think a significant economic impact that
we have to bear in mind uh from the
point of view of being able to transport
Goods across uh our districts and into
the country at large uh because we are a
vital Link in that process and finally
um coming back to the issue of the
citizens advice uh representation uh as
councilor Mullins pointed out you know
we already have uh several counselors as
well as officers uh on that advice
Bureau and clearly we all agree that
they do excellent and vital work and
surely there must be some mechanism by
which those existing counselors can
report back especially as some of them
are district councilors in the first
place so uh you know that's kind of my
take on the situation and I think you
know um I will be voting accordingly
thank you
thank you before I go on to the next uh
the next person just a reminder to
everybody the chat's not there there's a
function of debates
um I told you what the chapters for
before the meeting so please stop using
it debates for debate if you've had your
time you've had your time if you have a
point of order please raise it but uh
don't use the chat to use debate is
everybody happy with that
great Casa Barista please
thank you Mr chair
um yeah actually two two murders of of
clarification really
um firstly Council staff seemed to think
that we had left Haven Gateway
partnership we haven't at this moment in
time
um in fact I've got a meeting this
coming week with them
um so you know we we're still there and
uh the view was that that you know we
possibly should have been leaving but
with the new information coming forward
which which you know is is very recent
then obviously I think we must stay
there because it could benefit us
tremendously
um also on East-West rail
there seems to be some communication
um things which have perhaps gone wrong
on this
um because I received
um probably a year 18 months ago I
received an invitation to attend their
meetings
and I have been attending both meetings
in Bedford as well as
um the the Eastern region uh meetings
which obviously they're probably the
more helpful to us
um but overall we've been you know I've
been meeting with the full Consortium as
well as the Eastern region area
um apparently no money was paid for that
so you know it's we we've had probably a
year or 18 months of free but uh
um it is useful because it could take
um with the port
um using more and more rail
um it could take uh vehicles hgvs and so
on off the A14 and that would benefit us
tremendously
um so you know both those things but I
didn't want people to not know that we
had been represented on there for quite
a little period
um before this
thank you Mr chair
thank you councilor uh councilor Morley
please
um
the points that I'd like to to talk
through
um having a having an observer on the
citizens advice Bureau
will make no difference to the services
supplied to our residents by the cab
cancel Austin seemed to imply that if we
didn't have an observer there our
residents would suffer that is
absolutely not the case the our citizens
advice Bureau
um work very well without having an
observer on the board we already have
our officers engaged in regular dialogue
with the citizens advice
and their support and when we give
financial support to the cab
the terror officers are regularly
engaged in
to my mind an observer would give us no
added benefit
and as Council Muller has already said
he is on he is already a trustee on the
board
and I am pretty sure that if there was
anything that was of any concern
raised in any of those meetings then he
would be straight on the phone to either
myself or our officers
in our communities team so I see no
personally I see no idea benefit
whatsoever in having an observer on
there that has no official status and no
standing
um on the cab
um on the tabled papers on the Suffolk
disabilities forum
um
it's quite timely actually because we've
recently launched our new Independent
Living service that ensures disabled
facilities grants reaches any of our
residents that need it and so
um I am I'm really happy to support that
final final recommendation that's become
known as 1.7 and I'm very happy to look
at this um
approaching both the Suffolk
disabilities forum and the
mid-sufficient disabilities forum and
for us to determine which one best suits
our needs and the needs of our residents
thank you chair
thank you uh councilor e Byrne please
thank you very much chair
um firstly I'm very disappointed that
we're even considering recommendation
1.4 about the reporting mechanism
um when Tim Passmore was leader um we
agreed that anybody on an outside body
should report to full Council so that
all councilors regardless of political
party
um are aware of what what the body they
are on is doing and they receive a good
report back it was agreed again under
leader
um Derek Haley
um so the fact that this just doesn't
happen and we've still got to agree this
again is really poor I think for the for
the council as a whole and you know
people may make comments about citizens
advice Bureau but if we have got members
on those book on that um organization or
any other organization or on any other
organization sorry then please send a
quick email around to all your fellow
counselors and say was that such such a
meeting this happened that happened just
for your interest you can easily delete
emails if you're not interested but we
really should receive full reports from
anyone who's on an outside body and I'm
I'm really shocked that we've got to
agree this yet again
um so I will be supporting that
um just on a couple of the other ones
citizens advice Bureau I think it's very
useful to have an observer because then
you've got someone who's quite neutral
who's not involved in the workings of
the organization and given the money
that we give to them each year and the
fantastic job they do I think be great
to have a neutral person observing
reporting back and on the East-West
training um
organization I think
um I I note um cancer booster's comments
which I appreciate
um but I think that would be great and
also it sits well with our current
climate Ambitions thank you very much
chair
thank you some wise words uh Terence uh
sorry counselor Carter please
thanks Mary I'm sorry
um yeah so just regards on the the
observe status of um
citizen device Bureau
um I do believe it would be beneficial
but we do currently well we don't
currently have any counselors currently
on there as a member of the council uh
as it's been pointed out that it's been
a an individual councilor in his own
right
um if it's an observer appointed by the
council we would hopefully be getting
observations being reported back into
the council which would be going to
every councilor and we'd have a bit more
it wouldn't be us influencing the this
of the um Bureau but it may have some
influence on our procedure and just
maybe going to offices
it doesn't what goes through to offices
and this seem as important isn't always
how it's interpreted by councilors and
how the feedback that we get directly
from members of public
so it may have a difference rather in
having just officers on on the board it
may help have an observer who may better
take a pre-public perspective thank you
thank you
finally sorry but problems with the
buttons there
um counselor Norris please
thank you Mr chairman
personally I would be very much in favor
of having an official representative
from the Council on the cab
I believe Mid-South makes the biggest
Financial contribution to supporting
them but it's not just a financial
contribution I think it's
actually presenting a moral support as
it were to to this team on the cab
actually by a physical presence there
um
on the East-West Consortium I yes I
would think that is very important that
we did have a representative on that the
Royal Line has in Thurston in need of
marker is an essential link
and
it's something that we should have some
sort of Voice Within
the Consortium on it
um
The Haven Gateway I think for the some
involved it's such an important
body
and I believe that it would be
beneficial to The District Council to
have a representative on that one so I
will be supporting all of those psycho
thank you uh councilor flatman please
thank you chair
um I just wanted to give members some
reassurance that I work closely with the
cab
um and Carol Carroll Eagles is often
emailing me with
um different points Etc and the officers
she works very very closely with our
housing officer and they bypass a lot of
um
you know problems just by a phone call
so we do work very very closely with
them um not so long ago um councilor
Morley myself and councilor hadtingham
we all went there and spent a really
good morning with them so you know we
are in there and we we do support them
fully I can assure you thank you chair
thank you
um councilor just in case you uh missed
my message a few minutes ago don't use
the text um for debate as we explained
when we started the meeting it's there
for points of order really or
notifications to the officers that you
might be leaving the meeting so stop
doing it
um Council scarf I can see your hands up
but you've already had your debate is
this for a point of order uh well it's a
point of clarification actually chairman
um and I wonder if you might allow it
um the
um agenda or appendix a uh I was going
to go back to
um how um we came to um recommend to
council
um the cab recommendation
um a couple of councilors have spoken
tonight who actually uh have said that
they wouldn't support it but it was a
joint unanimous vote cross party and
actually uh proposed by and seconded by
two members of the administration of
this Council so I'm a little bit puzzled
and I just wanted to clarify that that
was what happened so that members were
aware that there was cross-party support
for this at the Joint overview and
scrutiny committee thank you for
allowing me to make that as a
clarification thank you I'll just
confirm that that's correct
um before we actually accept it so just
in case there is an a review on it just
bear with me
um Emily you'll perhaps you can help out
thank you chairman I did actually look
up the minutes of the overview and
scrutiny meeting because of the query
that had appeared in the chat and if I
can just read out the resolution
um so for this particular item cancel a
well and proposed recommendation 1.1
which was seconded by councilor scarf
by mid-suffolk District Council five
votes to one and that was specifically
that consideration be given by
mid-suffolk District Council that an
observer be appointed to stowmarket
Citizens advice
thank you chair
thank you for the clarity always good to
get a balanced view of everything really
so um we're now I can't see anybody else
just let me scroll down a second anybody
else with a hands up for the debate it
was a healthy debate some very good
points made and from it I basically
decided in fact councilor wallum well
I'm going to give you a chance to reply
in a minute but um if you just hang on
that be really good
um so it's a healthy debate
um so uh basically I I have looked at it
I've decided that we are going to break
this down into blocks when we come to
the vote uh over to you councilor well
and you've got anything else to add and
I'll explain the breakdown very shortly
uh chair yes um yeah if I may there's
one or two points I would like to make
um and one is to do with the East West
rail Consortium it was
um
it was going to the Brewster who advised
us that he was not attending the
meetings regularly and it had and they
were very short meetings and
um and he felt you know it's unnecessary
to pay pay the subscription because they
because of that but now we hear that he
is attending them regularly that's
that's that's very good news but we
haven't heard we haven't heard anything
back so we we didn't know that so
um I still think the recommendation
stands that we should consider paying
that but we would like to to hear back
if these are quite regular meetings
um it's quite right we are still a
member of The Haven Gateway and it
wasn't
that we should rejoin it was that we
should
um consider withdrawal and I mean we're
still we've still got that as as the
recommendation but of course in the
light of the extra information then that
can be considered and and and uh we stay
in if that's the view on the point of
templates
um
overview screen attempted to get
responses back from representatives in
the previous uh Municipal year and
received very little and so overview of
scrutiny felt that they had to find a
way of making it easier for
representatives to report and
for those templates or the remarks in
those templates to be used to review the
representation next year
um that's where that came from and if I
can just say a few things about the um
the discussion that we had
um in regard to the um
uh citizens advice
um
I mean I I also read
uh on the in the appendix a where it
says
consideration be given by mid-suffolk
District Council and observer be
appointed to
snow Market citizens advice in in line
with labor District Council and my
recollection is that the councilor at
ping Yong did in fact propose that I
couldn't remember who seconded it but
that is how it is set out
um on the last one page that those two
names are given beneath the um the
comment about the Citizen's advice
um so I'm quite surprised if Council
Epping on is now not uh supporting that
in any case
um a councilor Observer can assist via
formal and informal contacts in quite a
different way from the way that
um the officers would report
um uh and and
it's not right to rely upon uh councilor
Mueller who has been appointed by Star
Market Town Council to to report back to
mid-suffers
Street Council uh it's also rather odd
that the Town Council and the and
Suffolk County Council feel it's
necessary to have a representation but
mid-suffolk don't
um when they are the largest funder so I
think we really do do need to that and
and I don't see any downside in having a
representative there
um it's got it's got to be positive
um and I feel quite strongly that
um when that is uh reconsidered by our
leader that our leader should
um
should come down in favor of appointing
a representative or recommending to
council a record a representative at cab
uh thank you chair I've got nothing
further to ask
thank you Council well and thank you for
the report
um so the way we're going to break this
down for the votes is that we will do on
Block 1.1 1.4 and 1.5 followed
individually by 1.2 1.3 1.6 and the
tabled recommendation which we're
calling 1.7
so
chairman yeah I'm sorry to be a nuisance
okay
I am finding it hard to find the actual
paperwork would it be could you just
name name exactly what they are I'm
going to read them out in full so this
has been a long debate and you'll all be
confused so the rich might of course
there's no confusion about what you're
voting for thank you no problem at all
so um we are going to move for uh 1.1
1.4 and 1.5 and I'll read them out
individually and this will be a group
so 1.1 joint overview and scrutiny
committee recommends to the councils
named that the following appointments to
outside bodies no longer requiring
representation be removed from the
appointments made based on the
information received will drop down to
the mid-suffolk district council element
which was joint Waste Management board
Suffolk joint emergency planning policy
panel we're also going to vote on 1.4
which is that's a reporting mechanism in
the form of a template for
Representatives on outside bodies be
established to provide valuable
information to members and public the
information to be presented as part of
the annual review of member
representation on outside bodies to the
Joint overview and scrutiny committee
and finally for this block 1.5 which is
that support and training be established
for members when appointed as
Representatives on outside bodies and
that's what we'll be voting on now so
I'll now ask the corporate manager
governance and Civic office to conduct
the electronic votes on 1.1 1.4 and 1.5
by clicking the plus sign in the top
right hand of the screen and selecting
attendance and voting in the voting tab
the vote for these agenda items will
show in blue and please click on the
blue line to start the vote thank you
thank you
okay councilor Brewster we're still
waiting for your vote
it's just come through thank you so
councilor Humphries can you give me your
vote please uh four councilor Phillips
four
that is unanimous thank you chair
thank you that is carried okay moving
back then to the next uh one that we're
going to vote on which is 1.2 and I'll
read that out as well uh joint 1.2 joint
overview and scrutiny committee
recommends that both councils consider
withdrawal from The Haven Gateway
partnership as the committee feels that
the partnership cannot demonstrate value
and relevance
um I think I'll get gender come in just
to to put that in clear words so we
fully understand it
thank you chair so when we start the
vote if
rural you need
if you want to be against withdrawal you
need to vote against
so I'm now going to open the votes and
if you can go to your screen as per
normal and select the voting button
thank you
foreign
Humphreys can I have your vote please
against and cancer Phillips against
thank you
chair that is five votes Four and Twenty
Eight against thank you
thank you that is lost uh moving back
now to the next one on the list now
we're going to go for 1.3 that
consideration be given to mid-suffolk
District Council that an observer be
appointed to stowmarket Citizens advice
in line with baber District Council
thank you chair so cancers will need to
vote for if they wish to go for a
pointing to Stone Market citizens advice
and against if they don't want to thank
you the vote is now open and if you can
go to your voting screen and select the
button thank you
thank you
councilor Humphries can I take your vote
please
uh against
cancer Phillips can I take your vote
please four
thank you
chair the Voting is 21-4 and 12 against
that is carried
moving on to now the next one which is
1.6 that mid Suffolk District Council
considers taking up the appointment of a
representative to the East-West rail
Consortium by making a payment of the
subscription fees required for full
participation
I'll hand you back to the um
corporate manager governance uh and
Civic office to conduct the electronic
vote
thank you chair so if counselors can
vote for representation or against
the vote is now open and you need to go
to your screen and wait for the Align to
go blue thank you
foreign
ER we haven't received your vote
are you able to vote verbally please
oh sorry we have just received it thank
you councilor Humphries can I have your
vote verbally please poor and councilor
Phillips four
thank you
chair that is unanimous thank you
thank you that is carried and now we're
moving to what's known as 1.7 which is
the additional tabled recommendation
that mid-suffolk District Council
approaches the Suffolk disabilities
Forum to establish whether former
Council of representation on the Forum
would be appropriate and possible and
that any appointment to the Suffolk
disabilities Forum be made by resolution
of the full Council
and I asked the corporate manager
governance and Civic office to conduct
the electronic vote
thank you chair again councilors if you
could vote for or against the vote is
now open and it should appear in your
top right hand screen thank you
cancer Stringer we we don't seem to have
your vote are you able to give it
verbally oh actually it's just come
through you must have a slight delay
thank you councilor Humphries can I have
your vote please four and councilor
Phillips
four thank you
thank you chair we have 32 votes four
and one abstention for a conflict of
interest thank you
but the chair is having a slight delay
getting his mute button to come off
we'll be with you shortly
[Music]
get it again sorry I'm back now
um so that is carried
um we're now going to move on to agenda
item 12 which is mc20 stroke 20 to note
decisions taken by the chief executive
during the covid-19 pandemic period
under delegated powers in accordance
with part two of The Constitution I'd
like to invite the monitoring officer to
introduce the report which is for noting
thank you chairman I'm pleased to note
the report which includes the scheduler
appendix a of the decisions taken by the
chief executive under emergency Powers
which are contained within the scheme of
delegations in part two of The
Constitution these decisions were all
necessary to support this council's
response to the covid-19 pandemic thank
you chair
can take questions
okay
so I'm back uh councilman so you have
your hand up
uh thank you chair yeah yeah I I have a
question
um about the timeliness of the reporting
back to full Council because two of
these decisions I'm not arguing about
whether the decisions are right or wrong
I haven't got a problem with that it's
just that they happen to have been in
July and August are two of them
um and I just want I haven't read part
two of The Constitution that fully but
we have had other Council meetings since
July and August and I just wondered why
they weren't reported then
no it's a very good question and well
worth raising uh Emily please
we constitute you should say that the um
decision should be reported at the next
practicable moment and ideally they
should have come to to council ahead of
of this timing
um but unfortunately this is the
earliest time that we've been able to to
report them and so I just apologize for
that and and say that in future we would
Endeavor to get them to the next meeting
of the council after the decision has
been made
apologies accepted
okay
um I know we've been here for two and a
half hours so therefore we all need a
break and that's what we're going to
take now so we'll adjourn a meeting for
a period of 15 minutes so therefore
everybody back here please ten past
eight
thank you
okay
um
welcome back uh almost three hours of
lapsed which means we're approaching
Guillotine uh therefore I'll now ask
corporate managing governance and Civic
office to take a vote to extend the
meeting
thank you chair
we need to proposal in a second to first
thank you my apologies can I propose it
on a second to please
so uh councilor Carter
they're happy to propose thank you
councilor Miller
happy to Second chair thank you thank
you
so can we take consensus if anybody is
against
um extending the meeting can they speak
now
thank you I'm taking that as Carrie then
share that's great thank you we're now
moving on to mc20 21 strategic Asset
Management plan
2020-2025. I'd like to invite councilor
Gould to introduce the paper and move
the recommendation in a report because
of gold please thank you very much uh uh
Chet may I start by apologizing for my
uh voice I'm trying to get over
laryngitis uh and it's it's very weak as
a consequence product I hope it lasts
the pace at least for this item thank
you very much yes indeed I I would like
to uh
um introduce the report and and move the
recommendation I'm delighted to
introduce our our new uh strategic acid
Asset Management plan you'd expect to
see a plan like this in an organization
uh like ours and its development marks a
significant step forward
the development to the plan has
presented a challenge not least because
of the availability and quality of the
data on our assets but despite the size
and complexity of the the task uh this
uh plan has been brought forward very
expeditiously and it's very timely and
welcome
I it seems to me that
um we were able to do this because now
we have the staff able to bring about
such a plan and I'd like particularly uh
to thank the assistant director as it's
an investment and the corporate manager
for strategic property for their
professional skill and hard work in
producing the plan the the plan is is
not one to sit on the Shelf but the key
to the effective management of our
assets it provides a strong framework to
ensure that we manage our property
assets effectively and efficiently over
the next five years and Beyond
the plan will ensure that we have a
consistent approach to decision making
whilst ensuring that decisions can still
be made on the individual
characteristics of the individual assets
within our portfolio
the council is ambitious and we seek to
use our land and property to help to
deliver more Housing Development within
our district support the delivery of
strategies for High Street and Town
Center regeneration and contribute to
carbon reduction and improve residents
well-being
uh the plan will enable us to best
manage our assets to help the council to
meet its strategic priorities and
objectives and to build great
communities uh for everyone to live uh
work visit and invest in uh what I'd
like to say by way of introduction and
say to move the recommendation at 3.1 in
the report and I'd call for someone to
second that please
thank you
thank you do we have a second day uh
councilor Morley please
yes thank you chair I'm really happy to
see this come forward and I'd like to
second the motion thank you
thank you
car School anything more to say sorry
no not at this stage thank you thank you
in that case we'll move to questions and
as before you can ask as many questions
as you'd like but it must be relevant it
must be to do with what we're talking
about right now the recommendation in
front of you and it must be a question
so who's first
counselor Phil please
uh I note that uh in power 7 3 it talks
about uh Port photo holder briefings I
was going to question whether there will
be briefings to opposition and to other
counselors on these matters as we go
forward you have to understand it's a
very long document I I may have missed a
few points but uh
good point Kelsey gold
you're on mute
sorry about that yeah
um yeah a good question and and actually
one thing about this plan is that it
um crosses so many of the activities uh
and and
projects that we have that and there
will be the opportunity for cancers to
become involved uh in the process not
just in terms of the the progress of the
plan itself but individual assets uh the
use of individual assets uh within it so
on my expectation is that uh yes the
council uh will be kept uh briefed and
and hopefully involved in plans and
projects as they progress thank you
thank you
obviously the rest is for debate but
really as an opposition we wish to be
constructive usually there will be
things we violently disagree with I
guess perhaps not too violently and
things we agree with and I think one
once as as we have half the councilors
in the council we we wish to have the
opportunity to be constructive and to to
move these things forward I I I
understand uh that uh cats the field and
I think one thing about the approach
that
um uh that that is taken in this report
in this strategy uh is to Marshal facts
data information about the assets that
we have so any debates and discussions
we have will be better informed for that
thank you thank you so uh councilor
Passmore please
uh thank you chairman yes it's just um
I'm interested I think the total value
of the assets listed down there is just
over six 6.1 million if I remember
correctly from the papers could I ask
Peter is this done by some external
valuer and how often might that be
updated because obviously asset prices
can vary thank you yeah the plan itself
will be uh updated although it's got a
five-year Horizon now it will be a
rolling program on on your specific
question I'd like to bring in either the
assistant director or the or the
corporate manager to answer that if
they're available to do so of course
yeah yeah please do
good evening and
with the evaluation of
this nation of the portfolio and that is
undertaken by an external party
um and it is in accordance with zip for
requirements so some assets are valued
on an annual basis
um others um I believe it's on a three
or five year Rolling basis
I think I didn't quite catch the
valuation of the portfolio that you
quoted I think it was six but it's on
page I don't know it's a higher figure
than the one that you stated I think
it's in the order of 23.
um
is it in the papers yes I got the wrong
one thank you
thank you Emily moving on to councilor
Weller please
no I didn't yeah
thank you Chad yeah I've got a question
on page 103.
um the carbon reduction plan
I read there that we're going to ensure
that new Council facilities are designed
and built or refurbished to the highest
standards of Energy Efficiency possible
but when it comes to housing we're only
going to support the delivery of a
sustainable specification for new build
housing acquired or developed for the
councils we're not going to
ensure or insist and insist upon I would
have thought we ought to be insisting
upon the highest possible specification
for our new build housing or our housing
acquired
thank you uh the question
uh we have had a little debate in in the
course of this uh producing this report
about the correct verbs to use but I
will um ask um assistant director again
to
um to to address your question thank you
thank you Emily
apologies struggling with the mute
button and sorry counselor William your
question was in relation to
um the standards that are applied in
respect of Housing Development and our
own occupational
um properties
yeah it was comparing if you're looking
at page 103 I don't know if you are
um
it's the talking about the new Council
facilities which are we're going to
ensure a design to the highest possible
standards of Energy Efficiency whereas
our second bullet down we're only going
to support the delivery of a sustainable
specification for new build housing
acquired or developed by the councils
we're not insisting upon it and I I
don't understand why we don't insist
upon it
so
um
my take on that is is uh in relation to
to language and so the carbon reduction
plan is a key priority for the council
and this um strategic Asset Management
plan will
um
support the carbon reduction plan
whether it's in relation to the delivery
of new new build housing or in relation
to the delivery of new
um assets and operational property for
our own our own use so whilst you may
have interpreted the language to have a
different approach that's certainly not
how how I interpret the document
so can I be clear then that we will
insist upon the highest standards of
Energy Efficiency possible when we're
considering either building our own
housing or acquiring housing from others
I don't think we used the word insist in
in any of them
yeah so we will ensure that there's an
appropriate approach to
um the delivery of sustainable
specification for our new build houses
in the same way as we would in terms of
any of our operational properties Azure
aware councilor well and we are
currently looking at the new build
um specification for our affordable
housing development program and your
point will I'm sure be picked up
um in in the development and Adoption of
that specification
thank you very much thank you thank you
both uh councilor Stringer please
thank you Jay very quickly page 81 uh
top of page 81. this is going to be a
development of a longer term housing
pipeline could I be assured we're going
to have a short and a median term
pipeline as well
Council gold please
yeah yeah the point about a longer term
uh pipeline is is to make sure that
there is a pipeline that will uh that
will that will
being full of the housing that we is
part two uh to to achieve some of that
pipeline is will deliver sooner rather
than later but it's the important thing
for us is to make sure that that
pipeline is is is continuous so as we as
we develop we have uh future
opportunities uh to continue with our
aspirations
thank you very much
thank you uh councilor William see your
hand up again is that is that stated
from last time
or do you have another question
okay thank you councilor Richardson
please
uh thank you Chad I just wanted to raise
a point of clarification if I may based
on um cancer stringer's question then
obviously in terms of our overall assets
as a district council we are through
mid-suffolk um growth limited we are
looking in the short and medium term to
deliver houses based on the existing
sites that we have at our disposal being
it's the need a market HQ site the still
Market medical Middle School site and
others within the district such as in
elmswell so obviously there is
absolutely a place within the asset
management plan for our long-term
pipeline there are immediate
um in the short term and medium term
there are Housing Development
opportunities coming forward so I think
that's that's absolutely something we
should consider within the broader
context of this paper thank you thank
you for that point of clarification I'm
sure it's well received
just looking down now it appears we've
come to the end of the questions uh
therefore we're going to move into
debate and remember that you can speak
once three minutes and it is timed who
wants to lead the debate
counselor Richardson please followed by
councilor field
uh thank you very much chair um I just
wanted to make a couple of brief
comments about this
um first I think I'd just like to thank
councilor Gould for the very
um eloquent and persuasive introduction
he gave to this report I think I will
just say that although Council you're
you may be struggling with your voice I
think we all heard you loud and clear
um so thank you very much for that that
very comprehensive introduction
um I did want to say
um a few points in in general I think
especially
I think the the initial question that
councilor
um field asked and the the answer the
councilor Gould gave was actually really
important about the broader impact of
the um the assets that we have and and
what they what impact they can have on
our broader
um corporate priorities so I'm
particularly looking at and again at the
risk of sounding like a broken record
um the impact that the asset management
plan can have on our well-being priority
and so the fact that we can deliver
housing to new design and technical
specifications the fact that we can
deliver fit for purpose Leisure
facilities and Open Spaces throughout
the district
um I think although that may be a
relatively minor part of the overall
um asset investment plan
um sorry so Asset Management plan um I
think there's a really important element
of it
um and so if you know I'm particularly
pleased to see that 61 of mid-suffolk's
existing asset base it is being used for
open and Immunity spaces I think that I
can have an enormous impact if we
improve on that in terms of our broader
well-being strategy so I think that's a
really really important aspect of of
this plan and so I'll absolutely be
voting in favor of the recommendations
set out in uh in 3.1 thank you very much
chair thank you councilor Phil please
thank you
I'll keep this short clearly this is a
very long comprehensive document
but I was a bit disappointed there's not
many much sign of course the party
involved in its development we would
hope that regular updates will involve
all members rather than be exclusive
but will we support it well clearly we
would not wish to argue for
disorganization and ad hoc actions to be
dominant
but we must retain some freedom of
action and opportunity for Innovation
and rapid response and adaption to
developing situations I hope the
document doesn't preclude that
it does appear to introduce some very
detailed control and I wonder whether
the volume of text really lets us
foresee every eventuality and prescribe
the correct response
nevertheless we are in totally in
agreement with some aspects of the plan
and the first sentence of the uh final
paragraph of the introductory statement
that is attached to it talks about our
councils are ambitious and we seek to
use our land and property to help
deliver more Housing Development within
our districts support the delivery of
strategies for High Street and Town
Center regeneration contribute to carbon
reduction and improve our residents
well-being uh you know there's clearly
no way any of us would disagree I think
with those sort of ambitions
there are as I say some areas where one
would have wished perhaps to have um
seen some differences
um there's certainly to my mind reading
through some question as whether we see
the council as an investment vehicle or
body focused on delivering services that
our residents require
maybe that's an accident of the in
English but it does read like the
investment vehicle in some places
uh one point that I didn't question
earlier on was will there be any uh what
sort of level of reporting will there be
will there be reporting by exception
um what has been effective what has
failed unfortunately things do fail or
like a press releases will we only be
reporting successes
there are questions to me whether the
the far data will be available online in
the way that seal records are
however with those few comments I think
broadly it is a comprehensive document
it's clearly good to be organized it's
clear to have a vision of where you're
heading it would be good if that was a
whole Council Vision rather than a
restricted one but on that basis I think
my group will be supporting this
thank you and I don't think that your
comments will be lost on on the people
are involved in this they're very very
relevant uh councilor Passmore please uh
thank you chairman I'd endorse what uh
John has just just said but I do want to
say I think this is a very very good
start I'm really really pleased to see
this I wish when I'd been leader all
those years ago I'd have the gump to
think about it but I didn't
um and I think the reason I think it's
so important and I don't want to go on
about the economic downturn and and this
because it can be very very gloomy but
we have to be optimistic about the
future and in order to do that we'll all
have different views on what we Define
as economic growth and there's nothing
wrong with that
um we will all look at different sectors
be it from energy green energy
um ICT food drinking agriculture very
very important the mid-suffolk and so on
but one of the roles I think of a local
Authority is to try and make an area
particularly attractive A-frame would
invest but also to look after all our
resident and businesses regardless of
their background or anything else to try
and make them feel comfortable at ease
and um basically making Suffolk
mid-suffolk a damn good place to come
and live and work in and I think this is
a very very good start because
we need to manage our assets and we also
I was very pleased somewhere in there it
talks about the social value and I can't
remember I think it's near the beginning
I think that's absolutely crucial
because there are certain things that we
organize and deliver on behalf of the
population that make it a better place
Harry's mentioned Leisure and amenities
these are really really important things
as well as land for development for
housing housing be it free market
housing social housing shared Equity all
of these things we can do and all I
would say is it's a very very good start
I'm sure there will be lessons to be
learned as we develop it as the economy
changes the environment changes and I
would be confident that there will be
that flexibility in it no strategy can
be fixed and set in stone for a long
time and if we all work together we can
adapt and change and move forwards and
make mid-suffolk I am banging the drum
here an even better place because it is
a fantastic part of the county
um and I think it's a very very good
start and I'm delighted to do it so of
course I will have no hesitation in
supporting this at all it's a great idea
thank you thank you Council Passmore and
uh yeah absolutely important about
inclusivity and also improving the offer
it's already a great place to live we
want it to be even greater
councilor Autumn please
uh yeah thank you chairman um yes I
think we could not support what's being
proposed here I have a couple of
reservations in the report under the
current Constitution
um anything over ten thousand pounds
obviously has to make a decision of the
cabinet but it is essential that members
are aware and there is an open system of
reporting any um decisions
um under that level
um so I'd like to know from the cabinet
member or from cancer Gould how the rest
of the council will have been formed on
that because I interject sorry to be
rude
um I don't think those figures are
correct and um I really don't so we're
going to ask a counselor sorry ask Emily
Ewell please to come in just to clarify
the figures
thank you chair yeah the scheme of
diligence in terms of the financial
standing orders
um do actually allow officers to make
decisions
um over that ten ten thousand pound
threshold so they don't have to go
through to Cabinet but the rule about
executive decisions is that any over a
value of ten thousand pounds must be
advertised so it is very open and
transparent in terms of those decisions
being made thanks chair
thank you I wasn't trying to be rude but
I just hope that clears things up well
that's me what the rule
the rule yes has to be open and
accountable
um and I am slightly concerned about
that
um I just would also like to refer to
page 135 paragraph 8.3
disposal disposal to community groups
and one of the sentences is that any
leases to a community group will only
occur at Market rent
um now I do have some serious concerns
about that because some of those
Community groups are probably only
surviving by
um volunteers by their own fundraising
so I really would urge the
um Council Gould as chairman of this
um
paper
or as the lead member for this paper to
have some discussion about that
um because I think it's it would be
not in the best interest of this Council
and a community group that they are then
forced
um to
um comply with a lease at current market
rates
chairman now actually counselor
yeah I made a look also to uh to system
director for helping it but
um my understanding is that
uh normally this would there is a
requirement for things to be done at at
market value however there can be
um some provision or opportunity for
less than that if there is a clear and
demonstrable
um social value as as it were that would
support uh less than best consideration
but I'll ask um the assistant director
to uh for an authoritative view on that
please do Emily please
apologies having problems with the
buttons again thank you chair
um in terms of that question counselor
often the intention is that any leases
that are at less than best value as
councilor Gould explained so there may
be circumstances where
um a
um less than best value or lesser Market
rent is payable but there will be a
transparent reason and decision-making
process and behind that so the intention
is that if there are any leases at less
than best value that decision will be a
cabinet decision and there will be a
paper to support
um the reason for that decision so
that's the intention
um I I can't find a page that you
referred to but I believe that is set
out within the within the document
thank you
um chairman uh with your Indulgence can
I just thank Emily for after many many
many many months getting the least
organized
um for Ralston Community shop
thank you thank you very much thank you
well done
okay
um counselor Morley please
thank you thank you very much chair
um I'd just like to
add a bit about
being a bit of a data nerd this this for
me is absolutely
I don't quite know how to put the words
in order
this is absolutely fundamental to our
decision-making process
if you don't know what your assets are
you can have no chance whatsoever of
managing them and so from a data that
driving our decisions from the data
perspective this is absolutely
fundamental to it and so I'm I'm really
pleased that uh councilor gaunt has
brought this forward and especially to
the assistant director and corporate
manager for for putting all this work
together because this has been a hell of
an amount of work in a really stressful
and difficult time when
um obviously they're they have other
duties as well in terms of supporting
our covid response
to actually bring forward a document of
this quality I think is fantastic so I'm
really pleased to see it and thank you
everybody involved
thank you councilor Morley um councilor
Gould would you like to add anything
just just
um a couple of um uh thoughts uh if I
may first
um this has come forward I'm I'm repeat
my appreciation of work the officers
have done on this because uh it's come
forward
um remarkably quickly from a very low uh
base
um and and I think it you know in this
sense yes a big job has been done but
it's to enable us those to to have as
Council Morley says uh a much better
more informed understanding about the
the assets we have and and how we might
use them the other point I quickly
wanted to make this this seems to be a
kind of misconception abroad that
um came back to something that Council
field said about
um the mutual exclusive if it is it were
of Investments and and and and and
Service delivery and Improvement for me
actually the Investments that we make
and improvements we make to our assets
is the means uh by which we can do more
into terms of service delivery and and
Improvement I'm finally just on
something that
um again cats and I think cats a lot and
also made reference to the way in which
the council is remains informed and
involved uh in this strategy and its
application it is something uh I would
be giving thought to uh to with uh with
the support of the assistant director
because uh it is something that I think
Bears a further consideration I I take
the points that are being made thank you
very much chairman
thank you and um
there are no other people want to debate
so I'll just round off in fact uh
councilor Wellen
your points please
councilor Willem I think you're on moot
oh I am
I think it's off now
yeah
sorry about that yes
um yeah going back to what uh councilor
Fields had a greater range of views I
think May well have had added value to
the document and understanding and
buying and I think
um when this document is reviewed I
think it would would definitely be
advantageous to to um seek views from
across the council can I just um ask one
thing and that is
whether or not the cost of managing 989
assets is greater than the cost of
managing 152 and if so should the staff
costs be a portion to the two districts
in the same ratio
um or or is the definition of an asset
different in the two districts
Kevin I can I consider that question
above my pay grade
Emily any thoughts
thank you
um so there is some difference between
the classification of the assets between
mid-suffolk and baber and I think that
is in part
um part of the difference between the
the number of assets held and assets
aren't
um
uh sort of Commodities like barrels of
oil so the number of assets probably
isn't the appropriate measure and to
determine the uh the the cost of
managing them so it's more about
um the number of cases uh a number of
um activities I suppose that are
involved in relation to those assets so
you know you can have
um a lot of time spent on one asset and
and very little time spent spent on it
on another
sorry uh hopefully that answers the
questions
um councilor field I see that your hands
up you've already debated
um I have I just wondered whether I
might point something out to you no no
it's not a debate but just at 4.6 new
Anglia local Enterprise partnership
quite correctly describes that
partnership and doesn't really indicate
its relevance to the document so you
might put that into game yeah thank you
and for those offices and counselors
involved in document please note that
uh so councilor Whitehead please
and thank you chair I mean I think
there's it seems to get confused between
things like Book value at a book cost
and value and when we're talking about
things like amenity land and hedgerows
and that kind of thing I mean how do you
really put a value on it but the one of
the key things we're trying to achieve
it says here is to ensure the property
assets make the optimum contribution to
the council's priorities and objectives
now most of the council's priorities and
objectives are qualitative rather than
quantitative so I think any concerned
people raised about are we making the
best value for money I mean the reality
is are we doing the best with these
property assets and I think we've got a
great team here we've got a great
database this perhaps since the
beginning of the end or or the end of
the beginning certainly not the end of
the end and it's a lot of work to do but
I certainly I'm very enthusiastic that
we've got a great team together and
certainly help out youth executive will
make sure that we always put the
resources we need here because these are
vital in a vital says and to make them
work the best and in both qualitative
ways
um the uh so I'm really enthusiastic and
very supportive of all this thank you
thank you I think we've come to the end
of debate
um so just to put my pen of worth in I
think it's a really professional
document uh you could be you should be
congratulated officers and councilors
alike for producing it uh it's forward
leaning um it's ambitious it's Brave
um but above all to me it's professional
and it says a lot about us as a council
so keep up the good work it's really
really good but as the last two
councilors just said this isn't the end
this is an evolving document and we've
all got a part to playing it
um so don't be shy come forward speak to
the people that are involved in it and
add to it it can only evolve and become
better so really well done on the work
before we move to the vote
um counselor um gold have you got any
last points you'd like to bring up
uh no and I thank you for that uh for
for the remarks you've just made no I um
I think we're all ready to move to the
vote uh thank you Jim
good okay so the recommendation will be
3.1 it is recommended that Council
approves and adopts the samp for 2020 to
2025 which is appendix one including the
transactions and Community transfer
policies set out in the samp as
appendices A and B and as we've
discussed and read so now it's the
corporate managing governance and Civic
office to conduct an electronic votes
thank you chair councilors can you
please open the vote in the app by
clicking the plus sign in the top right
hand corner and selecting attendance and
voting the line will show in blue please
click on that blue line to open the vote
thank you
I'll give it one more go
no eligible to vote
no you haven't needed you
[Music]
I'll just ask him
councilor Carter do you want to give
your vote verbally please
okay it's just come through so councilor
Humphreys can I have your vote please
four
and cancer Phillips four
thank you
okay chair that's 30 votes four and one
against thank you
thank you that is carried and moving on
to a gen item 14
mc2022 time table of meetings
2021-2022 I'd like to invite councilor
Morley to introduce the paper and move
the recommendation in a report councilor
Morley please
thank you chair
report mc20 22 for the timetable of
committee meetings
it's really important that we get all
these dates into our Diaries as soon as
possible
um especially in these these funny times
where we don't know whether we're going
to be meeting virtually or whether we're
going to be meeting in real real offices
Perhaps Perhaps never again who knows
but it's in order to enable the the
business of the council to progress at
speed
because we have a hell of a lot of
things that we want to be doing we need
to get these dates into our Diaries as
soon as possible so I'm very happy to
propose the adoption of this timetable
and I would call for a secondary thank
you
foreign
thank you
okay
um
unless there are any questions that are
actually on a report
about the report that I tend to put
recommendation straight to the vote
uh councilor field C Hunter
thank you there is a question it's
almost traditional that I ask surely to
God there is a version of this sitting
on Microsoft Outlook
so I can attach it to my calendar
without typing hundreds of things into
it it's sort of about efficiency and
things like that I think I do have the
Democratic service one but it will be
nice if there was one that attached
readily please please please
like I used to do at BT in 1990
something rather eight
just to give you an answer so so chair
thank you for that just to to let you
know that we have been trying to do this
but there is a problem with the I.T that
talks to Suffolk it and we are in
dialogue with modern.gov and Suffolk it
to try to get this resolved thank you so
2029 yeah put it in your diary
of the democratic service one so it can
be done it can be done um they're going
to work on it and we'll take we'll take
that away obviously uh councilor
mathiason please
full Council meetings on this timetable
to ensure a proper level of
accountability I just wanted to say that
thank you thank you and your point is
noted and will be will be taken uh as
you as you just said it so we're now
going to move
um towards the the vote so before we do
that the recommendation is that the
draft committee timetable for 2021 2022
be approved I'll now ask the corporate
manager governance and Civic office to
conduct the electronic votes
thank you chair if cancers can again go
to the button the plus sign and commence
the voting thank you
counselor Humphreys can I have your vote
verbally please or and cancer Phillips
four thank you
thank you chair that's 28 4 2 against
and one abstention thank you that is
carried we're now going to emotional
notice motion received from councilor
Morley
um councilor Morley would you like to
move the motion please
yes thank you chair
so the District of mid-suffolk has a
long and proud association with the
Jewish community and was a refuge for
children fleeing persecution by Nazi
Germany through the Kinder transport who
came to live with Foster families in
this District
sadly many of those 10 000 children who
arrived in the UK were never reunited
with their birth parents who died during
the Holocaust
looking for a reminder of why tackling
hate crime is so important and the
potential consequences that can arrive
arise when it is allowed to go unchecked
on Wednesday the 27th of January the UK
will Mark Holocaust Memorial Day
when we will remember the billions of
people murdered during the Holocaust and
in the genocides that followed in
Cambodia Rwanda Bosnia Kurdistan and R4
and those that preceded the Holocaust in
the 20th century and earlier
this is a timely opportunity for us to
adopt the international Holocaust
remembrance alliance definition of
anti-semitism as part of our commitment
to tackling hate crime in all of its
forms
therefore it gives me great pleasure to
propose that we strengthen our
commitment to tackling hate crime
towards Jews by adopting the
international Holocaust remembrance
alliance definition of anti-semitism
this definition which was adopted by the
UK government in 2016. Outlaws all forms
of hatred towards Jewish people
including rhetorical and physical
manifestations of anti-semitism
adopting this standard does not mean
that we place any religion Faith or
Creed above another
it does however send a clear message
that the council recognizes the
definition of anti-semitism ahead of
Holocaust Memorial Day and that we
support our Jewish Community as we
support all communities within our
district to live here safely and to be
proud to call mid-suffolk home
I urge all counselors to support this
motion and send a clear message to those
who seek to sow seeds of hatred
thank you Jim
thank you councilor Morley
um to have a second to please
counselor hadingham
cursor hallingham you still there
I think you're still muted
yeah coselling I can see that you are
looking to second I'll just give it a
couple more seconds to try and get you
back online
[Music]
we're not picking anything up at all
um have you got your video on
I don't know whether it helps you but I
can see councilor hardingham
um
I I can't because she's not speaking
see don't lose I I believe that you're
trying to Second put your fingers uh put
your thumb up if that's correct
yes okay so we do have a second there
and we will come back to you because you
do have a right to speak and we'll come
back probably at the end of debate which
gives you time to try and address the
issues you're having with your I.T
is everybody content with that
excellent right in that case
um we will now uh go into debate
um who wants to lead it
uh Council Passmore
thank you very much chairman I am very
pleased to support this um motion
I have to say that uh the long history
of persecution of Jews and for that
matter for other people regardless of
their faith and so on is completely
unacceptable we all know that
intolerance Prejudice bigotry leases can
leads to civil disorder Strife lack of
community cohesion and in any tolerant
liberal Society there is no place for
that and hopefully there never will be
you might be interested to know that um
during the last year Suffolk constabri
has courted just under a thousand cases
of hate crime
uh fortunately it's starting a very slow
decline but we must remember that
probably it's one of these um crimes
that is underreported and fed almost
certainly it is and any other day in
John whiteheads and Mike and um Council
Ward there is an alleged case of racial
Prejudice and abuse and hate crime in
Clayton which is now being investigated
I just wish that people would actually
look forwards instead of backwards and
understand that this country and this
county has always had a proud history of
looking after refugees and go back to
the French huguenotes at the beginning
of the uh I think it was the 19th
century after the Declaration of nunt
and as our leader has just said the work
that we've done with children due to the
Nazi persecution and so on is second to
none last year I was privileged and I
really do mean that to everybody to go
to the Holocaust memorial celebration
Suffolk that was held up at southworld
and I have to confess it brought tears
to my eyes when I saw some of the things
that had happened
so anything I can do as an individual to
try and combat this you can certainly
count me in for that so I would urge
everybody to support this motion
and please remember whilst in this
particular case we're talking about the
Jewish Community it also applies to
other people as well
and in my police and crime commissioner
role we do invest over 300 000 pounds a
year of yours and my money tax Suffolk
taxpayers money in the victim service
that we run with our colleagues in
Norfolk to try and provide help support
and encouragement for those that have
been suffering from Prejudice hate crime
whatever you like to call it to come
forward so these can be investigated
and one of the
facets that will be in the um new police
and crime plan sorry the new budget for
next year
will involve a little extra resource for
dealing with hate crime raising the
awareness to try and make sure we rid
ourselves of this and particularly for
the Jewish community and others that is
what we need to do it's the Hallmark of
a civilized society that we don't
tolerate this and we all work together
to make sure it doesn't happen thank you
chairman
thank you Council Passmore and putting
the figures on and a real true stories
of today is really important and
supports this motion I'm sure uh
councilor Phil please
thank you
I have to say our group was mildly
surprised to find this motion being put
to council as we're not aware of
significant problems in mid-suffolk they
were obviously fully aware of the
international problems that exist and
perhaps those in some areas of the UK
I'm pretty surprised and appalled to
hear
councilman passmore's comments about
Clayton which is a visit Village
there's certainly in my County Ward
um
however it's always easy as someone
that's from a group that's not at risk
of this normal attack to form a judgment
that maybe there isn't a problem
and as we are close to all those course
Memorial Day we find motion totally
appropriate
both the parties that form a group of
strong Believers in equality have a long
history of action against hate crime and
the abhorrence of any form of
anti-semitism
if as we hope the statement from
mid-suffer of Miss suffolk's position
discourages anti-semitic attitudes
within our area of influence then it has
real value and has a total support
I do one day if at another time it will
be appropriate to agree similar
statements from other groups that suffer
from prejudiced attitudes height crime
but perhaps all are covered by our
equalities policy so I'll repeat again
we're sort of fully in support thank you
thank you very much and uh councilor
Richardson please
um thank you very much chair um I'm very
privileged to be a part of this debate
this is actually something which is
um Incredibly Close to to my heart
um when I was 17 I was very fortunate to
be involved
um in the Holocaust educational trusts
um lessons from Auschwitz program so I
visited
um Auschwitz birkenau
um several years ago now and obviously
though it may be a ruin of what it used
to be
um I can still say with my hand on my
heart that it was the most harrowing
experience of my life so this is
something that I'm really passionate
about
um and I think this is absolutely the
right
motion that we should be passing as a
district council if I can just reflect
briefly on the um history and the
context behind this particular
definition that we're being asked to
consider as I think councilor Morley and
others have said this is a a definition
that's been adopted by not just the UK
government but by other International
your partners as well but just looking
within the UK it was I think first in if
I've done my research correctly it was
in October 2016 that the home Affairs
select committee recommended the
adoption of this definition and then in
December of that year that the UK
government formally adopted the wording
of this definition for anti-Semitism but
it's not just the UK government either
it's also been the Welsh and Scottish
governments the greater Manchester
combined Authority the London assembly
and over 120 English councils that have
adopted this motion in fact I did a
little bit a little bit of research
before this and and there was only one
Council that I could find that's ever
voted and rejected this motion and which
is mendip District Council in in
Somerset so the vast majority of not
just National bodies but but local
councils as well that have adopted this
motion so I really think that there's if
it's if it's emotion if it's a
definition and that's good enough for
for all of those bodies and I don't see
why mid Suffolk should be any different
um and if I can I I can understand why
cancer field says that there's a degree
of surprise as to why this has come
forward now but actually if I can come
at this from a slightly different
perspective
I'm only surprised that we haven't
actually adopted this far sooner
um I think absolutely this is time right
to coincide with Holocaust Memorial Day
but I think this is actually a really
important
um way of understanding in the which
sorry I'm way of understanding the way
in which anti-Semitism does
um
does persist in in various different
tropes in various different ways of
um of what ordinarily might be described
as our public discourse so I think this
is a really important notion and I will
absolutely be supporting it thank you
chair
thank you and um very informative yeah
well said uh moving on to councilor
mayor please
thanks chair
um I'm going to try and choose my words
very very carefully I thoroughly support
the words within this motion
but the motion itself worries me
if you turn a spotlight onto something
you show that area in great detail but
everything around it is in Shadow is in
darkness
I think this motion potentially could be
divisive
what will a community living in
mid-suffolk who feels they're being
discriminated again think when they see
the Jewish Community held up on a
pedestal and put in a spotlight
will they get their time in that
Spotlight are we going to have motions
every month coming forward trying to
sweep up every group that feels they're
discriminated against
with that if we will
so
is this motion divisive I worry that it
is
I shall not be voting for it
I shall abstain and by abstaining
I'm trying to establish my position I am
against discrimination in any form
wherever and whenever it occurs
what
better way to remember those who died in
the Holocaust
not to put forward a statement that this
Council
will work tirelessly to remove
discrimination whenever and wherever it
occurs
we're not doing that
we're picking on one group and we're
spotlighting that group and by doing so
we're forcing every other person who
feels less discriminated into the
Shadows
that in itself I feel is discriminatory
and I'm really disappointed that we as a
council have not put forward a stronger
case that I'm sure everybody here this
evening feels that discrimination has no
part to play Within mid-suffer
thanks Jay
cosuma thank you for your for Uganda
really and um I think you've
you've actually brought balance to the
debate and that's not a bad thing and
and we totally understand where you're
coming from I'm sure we'll continue with
the debate with councilor Mansell please
um I am I I completely understand where
um councilman is coming from actually
um you know I I too like cats the field
was quite surprised to see this on our
agenda because because although I am
aware of hate crime
um I feel quite privileged actually to
be the council's representative on the
community safety partnership and I've
I've had the opportunity to go to hate
crime conferences and I and it is often
something that we discuss at the
community safety partnership meetings
but but I wasn't in any way particularly
aware that there was a big issue about
the Jewish Community uh being recipients
of hate crime in our area
um and having now listened to councilor
mayor I I maybe I'm going to reconsider
because I I think we should be doing all
that we can to to stop discrimination
against any group of people and we
should be doing all that we can to get
rid of hate crime but I I and having
having listened to me and I'd like to
thank him for saying that because it has
made me think about it and think well
well yeah maybe this is actually
pointing out
um a specific group and in that we are
we being discriminatory against all
other groups so I will consider my
position and when it comes to the vote I
will I will have to make a decision
about which way to go
um so I'd like to thank the previous
people who've spoken
um because I I think that this isn't as
straightforward as I first thought it
was thank you thank you very much and
moving on to councilor Carter please
all right yes I just wanted to come
forward how supportive I am of uh what
councilor mayor has uh the points he's
raised I'd say I am now in quandaries
whether or not it's gonna if I do the
same as him is it going to reflect as I
uh it may look it's a vote and may
appear that I am not in support of this
motion when I
I'm supported I am against
discrimination of any form
so do I do the same as him and risk the
out of a Fallout or do I do if what I
what it's in their impassions and very
well spoken by Spoken and well put out
argument
um so that's really put me on a it put
me on a quandary put me on it it put me
on a fair so thank you very much
councilor mayor
um
I guess I should ask my local label like
representative but um we can get onto
this shortly thank you
thank you
um counselor
I'm erosion please
hi thanks
um chair
um
again I guess we should choose our words
carefully around this being um
as a controversial subject as it is
um but of course
I um agree with the motion
um
also agree and thank councilor mayor for
his uh
nuanced take on it
um
but I'd also like to point out one point
of uh contention with emotion actually
that um I think is
worth just cautioning on
um and that is
the second last point in the in the
bullet point list
which is drawing comparisons of
contemporary Israeli policy to that of
the Nazis now I think we could agree
that's that would be massively
distasteful
um but it's the distinction of of
calling
of equating Israeli policy with the
Jewish Community which I think is is
worth just
at least a slight eyebrow raise
um in this instance
um but I acknowledge this is uh a widely
accepted document
and um
it can probably be overlooked but I just
think it's worth making that point
um but going as to how we'll vote um
yeah I feel similarly
um
uh confused by uh Richard Mayers
councilor Richard Mayer's uh comment and
yeah I think we should take that under
strong advisement and perhaps look to
Pivot to a more generally uh
emotion more generally against
discrimination of any kind yeah that
might that might be quite a powerful
statement to make as a council thank you
uh thank you very much
um I'd just like draw your attention to
that I guess that was the second from
last bullet point uh drawing comparisons
contemporary Israel Israeli policy to
that the Nazis
um
well I don't think you can compare the
Nazis with anyone actually and I think
that bullet point stands but that's
that's my personal Point
um councilor Stringer please
thank you chair slightly struggling with
the technology
um yeah I think we should be careful
with our language at all times not not
just discussing very sensitive Motions
like this and quite rightly so
um
I I think we should
uh out discrimination wherever we see it
in whatever form and and and out here as
the Imposter that it is
uh this particular
series of discriminations has been a
blight on many societies for far far too
long uh and we should out it wherever we
see it and we just because we're in a
rural area of Suffolk we shouldn't think
it doesn't mean us and it doesn't happen
here
I I I have among my not enough friends
but among my friends met many Jews that
I know uh and some of them are actually
quite appalled at his Israeli policy
so it is wrong to conflate all Jews with
Israeli policy that's just
discriminatory and actually it's untrue
so that should be in in that in that
bullet list
um I I think we actually owe it to all
of those also that fell victim to the
humanitarian outrage that was the
Holocaust it wasn't just Jews that that
were in that Holocaust but just because
the whole list isn't a comprehensive
list that we have here
doesn't mean to say we shouldn't support
it of course we should support this and
if every community that feels it's
discriminated against comes forward
that's brilliant that's not keeping
people in the dark that's allowing
people to come into the light and we
should do that I think we need to be
very mindful of what happened in America
uh less than three weeks ago the utter
total outrage at what happened there was
found by some of the absolute myths and
outrages that this proposal seems to
Outlaw which is what we should do you
just need to look at some of the
t-shirts and the outrageous slogans on
those t-shirts about the Holocaust and
about Jews by some of those people that
storm that Parliament so I have
absolutely no problems with with
supporting this motion and if other
motions come forward from those that
feel they're discriminated in my
community I will back those as well
thank you chair thank you very much uh
Council please
um I think that uh the contributions
that my fellow counselors have been
making
throughout the course of this debate
have been well argued and uh point to
certain elements that are incontestable
with regard to the issue of
um racism and other horrible things that
we as human beings can do to each other
I have lived in in large cities in the
UK large cities in America have lived
here in the Beautiful
Countryside of mid-suffolk a place I
really love now
and I can assure you that
um racism and all kinds of iniquity
happen here just as they do everywhere
and therefore we as a council should
take a stand against such iniquities and
believe me that it is not just a
question of white versus black I can
assure you that it's also black versus
white I have been there I have had
discrimination from both sides of the
flag as it were and it is a horrible
place to be
but I do take on board councilor mayor's
point which is that we really as a
council ought to be addressing
iniquities across the Spectrum it is
there's no doubt nobody would argue I
certainly wouldn't argue that what
happened during the Holocaust with a
horrible nasty thing and we should try
to avoid that and councilor Morley in
her introduction pointed to other
genocides and and horrible
um inflictions that have happened even
in this Century
um so to me a stronger more powerful
statement would have been a motion that
was inclusive of all those groups and I
find that you know we are being asked
almost to kind of pick and choose which
I think is not quite right
um and I do think though we do need to
make some we should make some sort of
statement about
um you know being anti-racist and then
you know Council if possible all you
know in his role as a commissioner of
police will will come across this in in
various forms
um and I think you know it in those
kinds of uh areas it is where we should
you know be focusing our attention to to
serve the widest community that we can
and I mean I live in stone market and
and I don't know if you've walked around
the High Street of Star Market of late
because every day has become more and
more Cosmopolitan Place
councilor and and uh that kind of
situation causes me to reflect very hard
on counselor release motion thank you
thank you uh councilor Fleming please
thank you thank you for the
up speaker I wasn't going to
go and just on this motion initially
because I fundamentally agree with it
but um I do want to say something
because
um
I absolutely understand what councilor
mayor is saying here
um but I'm I I'm nevertheless going to
vote for the motion
because I think
um as possibly I find myself agreeing
with councilor Stringer
um much to everyone's surprise possibly
um but
you know I think we do have to take a
stand where opportunity allows and thank
you councilor Morley for giving us this
opportunity any form of racial bias is
fundamentally wrong
and um you know I think that needs to be
that message needs to be sent out by
this district and uh and I and I fully
support this message but um it also
symbolizes our position with regard to
any sort of discrimination of any kind
now the Jews in particular
have suffered most
um
most notably during the Holocaust and
possibly you know this is a complicated
situation the israeli-palestine
situation is is complex and is different
to the situation where we um we're
looking at discrimination against Jewish
people but I absolutely do support this
motion and I support any initiative that
reduces
um you know our are seeking to
differentiate People based on their race
or origin because that is not or sex or
anything like that because absolutely
that is not what we should be doing and
um I just simply wanted to make that
point tonight thank you
Coastal custom please
thank you very much Mr chairman
um I'm really proudly going to vote for
this motion tonight I am I can
understand what other councilors have
said on this one
um but I really do not believe that this
makes any The Shining Light on this
makes any areas any darker I think this
this is looking at anti-semitism
and it's still around in 43 governments
have policies the anti-semitic the um
it's it's a really serious issue and um
with the Holocaust
um Memorial
um day coming up I think this is the
right time to be putting this motion
through Council the um the the Jewish
people have been persecuted for for
thousands of years it's not just the
Holocaust it it was czarist Russia the
um the Roman Empire there was ever such
there's been so much scapegoating of the
Jewish people throughout such a long
time that I'm I'm really happy to um to
back this motion um tonight it's it's
something really important to me I've um
I have I've got many Jewish friends and
Andy's semitism does exist
it's in this country and it is around I
I think um we speak to um any Jewish
person and who could easily be something
that they've experienced in the past so
um yeah really happy to support this no
motion well done councilor Morley for
putting it in
um I'll be voting for it tonight
thank you councilor War boys please
no
thank you thank you chair
um yes I I I'm going to support this
motion I think it is a timely
uh motion to bring forward at this time
anti-Semitism is a long and tragic
history throughout Europe and
and within the UK uh the the massacre of
the Jews in York in the Middle Ages and
the raid of King John is an example
um anticism anti-Semitism is on the
increase
um
in in uh 2019
uh there was a seven percent increase of
anti-Semitic
attacks
uh most of these involved abusive
Behavior verbal abuse graffiti or abuse
via social media
and and I think
councilman that's a very
wise words I think this is putting a
spotlight on a particular aspect of
racism
xenophobia intolerance and how
people
use this anti-semitic tropes
to
abuse people of other races and cultures
and religions
and perhaps
voting for this motion and accepting
that Within
um bit Suffolk District Council will
give us some guidance on how we can set
shed light in further afield and to look
at other forms of racism and xenophobia
and intolerance and how they damage our
communities
thank you
thank you counselor
uh counselor having a dissert kombucha
if you wish to speak uh are you able to
speak yes can you hear me now yes I can
please carry on good I just want to say
I agree with you know most things have
been said and I appreciate that the
debate I think it's been a very good one
but um and I just want to say that
before I make my speech I just want to
say that of course all racism is wrong
but to add insult to injury apparently
six percent of this country either
believe that the Holocaust didn't happen
or it's been greatly exaggerated and the
Jewish people are meant to take that on
the chin which I think is an awful shame
you know let me read my speech I'm very
happy to Second this motion and implore
you all to vote in favor of it whilst I
was the chairman of this Council I had
the privilege privilege of attending
last year's Holocaust Memorial Day held
at the Abbey Gardens in Berry which was
a beautiful and moving ceremony I also
attended a Hanukkah celebration at
Ipswich Town Hall hosted by the mayor
Jan Parry along with my daughter which
we both thoroughly enjoyed especially
the singing and the dancing there we met
many interesting and wonderful people
but also heard some heartbreaking
stories for them from them some of the
some of them are children they're only
surviving some of some of them are
children of the only surviving member of
their family who are lucky enough to
escape with their lives often helplessly
waiting for family members who never
arrived
you could think that in this day and age
there's no need for such emotion that
we're proposing tonight but if the fact
is there's still very much
discrimination about and it's regularly
reported in the media
the sad fact is these perpetrators of
these shocking and monstrous lives and
abused towards Jewish people feel so
unashamed of themselves because they
think we all feel the same way as they
do this motion is sending the clear
message that we do not please support
this thank you
thank you very good points nobody else
at the debate uh well I've listened to
the debate and I've listened with
interest and it's very balanced and and
it's it's an emotive subject but it's an
important subject we shouldn't shy away
from it
um I've personally seen the very worst
that people can be to people and I've
seen the effects of this hatred going
out of control because there are no
policies no regulations and importantly
nobody said stop or no and that was the
Bosnian War
um where genocide occurred I was there
and uh all sorts of other things that
happened there were probably just
similar to what the Nazis were doing in
Nazi Germany all those years ago yeah
that was only 1995 because there's no
policy no regulation everybody got on
board
um I was lucky that I went back and I
hunted down war criminals for a while
and I was very pleased to do that but
when these people were caught they were
normal people
now probably not normal in there but
they were you and me okay and without
regulation without policy without
remembering what went on without some
form of law chaos will issue
so in the European continent in 1995
this was going on and I'll be it wasn't
the Jews there were thousands and
thousands of people men women and
children killed because there were no
policies no regulations and no reason to
stop it so I will be voting for this
without a shadow of a doubt
um I welcome it but I also take away
from this that it's not just about
having this policy
um for all the reasons we've got it and
for all the rights that's within it and
we need it for everybody and we need to
change opinions we need to change the
way people act and we can only do that
really by facing it head-on as this
motion does and stating what we won't
accept and stating the way we want to go
forward and live so I'll support it
are there any other points
cool uh councilor Morley
um you've got a right to comment uh
before we go to the vote
thank you very much chair
um it was interesting that actually the
councilor Passmore mentioned the the
huguenots because
um I myself have six different lines
of of huguenots who fled France
um and turned up in spitalfields in
London destitute with just the clothes
on their backs some of them having fled
in apple barrels hidden while they're
traveling across the the channel so I
know exactly what he means about about
the huguenots
um and I I've Got a Friend also who's
whose family
a Jewish and they were born in this
country but their parents and The Wider
family the aunts the uncles cousins were
all in the Hague at the time the Nazis
invaded
and
she'd asked me to investigate her family
history because her father refused to
talk about it because it was so dramatic
and
I had the privilege of searching through
all the
um Holocaust records following the war
trials
in the hike
after the second World War
and
after I'd gone through all those
death records I had to go back to my
friend
and tell her that nearly 30 members of
her family had been murdered in
Auschwitz and sobibor
I just cannot tell you how emotional and
upset
that made me
and
I do want to make it clear that
we already have an adopted equalities
and and a diversity policy already
defined and upheld
by this Council and it covers everything
that we do
so it's
this is and this this motion is just
adding to that policy by defining what
anti-Semitism actually means it is not
about placing one form of discrimination
in advance or overarching any other form
of discrimination discrimination in all
its forms has no place whatsoever in our
society or our Council
so and this is also about showing
leadership and making a clear statement
about the things that we value and what
we stand for as an organization and as a
district regardless of whether there are
lots of incidents just one five hundred
five thousand it doesn't matter if there
is even one
we stand against it and so I I urge you
all of you to support this motion
without reservation thank you
thank you councilor Morley so um we've
had the debates and now that's the
corporate managed governance and Civic
office to conduct the electronic votes
thank you chair councilors can you
please open the vote in the app by
clicking the plus sign in the top right
hand of the agenda screen the agenda
item will show in blue and click on
click on the blue line to open the vote
thank you
okay
um
councilor Humphries can I have your vote
verbally please
get the mic on uh yes I'm for and
councilor Phillips can I have yours
please four thank you
for four extensions
chair the voting was 26 for the motion
with four abstentions thank you
thank you therefore that is carried
um moving on to the final Point really
so Council appointments are there any
changes to policings
want to make chair thank you thank you
okay and there are no others fantastic
um so the date the next meeting is
Thursday the 18th of February 2021 at 5
30 p.m thank you for everything you've
done tonight um for the debates I think
it's been really healthy it's been very
balanced uh and thank you for the way in
which you conducted yourself
um I now close the meeting at 21 35.
thank you for your attendance